you know I think we're headed towards
the uh Civil War and you know why I say
it right off the bat audio has leaked of
a a republican in Arizona trying to
bribe Carrie Lake offering her a
lucrative position at some company if
she drops out of the senate race
he says in this audio recording that the
election in Arizona was stolen secret
recording and he says at the end in a
manner of speaking if they find out if
this goes public if he releases this
information he will be
assassinated what he literally says is I
will put my key in my car
and as if to imply they will murder him
if he reveals what's actually going on
behind the scenes presumably Carrie Lake
herself recorded this audio I don't know
for sure the audio has been released and
we can listen to it it's been published
by many news outlets and they say that
they've reached out to members of the
GOP in Arizona who have confirmed it is
in fact this uh it is in fact a member
of the GOP who's doing this we'll get
into all the details on it the reason
why I bring up Civil War stuff is I
could not imagine in my lifetime the
powers that be losing such control that
audio is released of them attempting to
someone running for office into bowing
out these are things of of myth and
Legend we can only speculate towards we
know something happened behind the
scenes we know something was wrong with
those voting machines in Arizona and now
there's an actual recording for 10
minutes where a guy saying maybe there's
a company we can get you some money just
disappear for a few years what's the
number this stuff's crazy and there's
other reasons why I say Civil War first
let's get through the Weeds on this one
Trump was already projected the winner
of the New Hampshire primary so that's
why I I really don't care about it it is
interesting in this story we actually
have Democrats being interviewed saying
they are literally Democrats voting for
Nikki Haley to sabotage the Republican
primary and then go vote for Joe Biden
not kidding I'll play the video for you
but this is not news I mean it is it's
interesting oh okay hey look Trump won
Trump has already been projected uh uh
to win but we'll see we'll see very very
few of the votes are in and some are
concerned this is trick so that Trump
voters leave and and and don't vote so
make sure you just you stick around and
you vote but the next major issue is
that following the Supreme Court ruling
in Texas that the feds have the the
authority to remove razor wire not only
did Texas announce that they will not
back down they will not allow feds to
remove the razor wire they actually just
brought more
in that is why I say wow Civil War
the unip party establishment machine is
losing a grip on its control and its
power the Epstein stuff somehow gets
released to the public these deep
backdoor conspiracies are being exposed
their power is their their grip is
slipping and now we have actual conflict
between states and the federal
government we're going to talk about all
that before we get started my friends
head over to cast brew.com bu cast brew
coffee it's our coffee company we
sponsor ourselves and when you buy
Casper you're supporting this show the
work we do and of course if you buy Alex
Stein's Prime Time grind two times
caffeine which is our our latest release
you're also helping cats because Alex
has requested that his his portion of
the sales will go to a cat charity and
we're excited to uh uh get that rolling
out but we're going to you know right
till the end of the month get total
number and then announce how much we're
going to be putting towards a cat
charity because Alex really likes cats
but uh make sure you check out Casper
coffee we've got rise with Roberto Jr
now I'm I'm sorry to say that the
Appalachian kns ground and K Cups
totally sold out whole bean is still
available but man this stuff is so
popular I'm I I'm eternally grateful for
everybody who's buying it they really do
love it that's the uh blend that I put
together that I personally liked and
it's just it's gone even here it's like
everybody goes for that one first so if
you want to support the show buy from
cast brew.com support our work but also
head over to
timcast.net coming up tonight at 10:
p.m. Monday through Thursday we at 10
p.m. and you'll also get access to our
Discord server where we can hang out
with like-minded individuals they have
pre-shows they've got after shows
commentary and as a member you can
actually call into the uncensored show
to talk to us and our guests so get
involved man support our work directly
over at timcast.net to also smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us tonight to talk about this and
everything else is Derrick Evans hey man
thanks for having me on the show really
appreciate it right on who are you what
do you do yeah uh my name is Derrick
Evans um married to my college
sweetheart I've been together about four
uh 15 years have four kids uh most
people know me as uh the state
legislator in West Virginia who went to
the capital on January 6th to peacefully
and patriotically protest the stolen
election and uh got arrested thrown in
prison and now I'm running for congress
well right on should be interesting you
have some good insights I suppose on how
all that stuff is going down especially
as you're talking about the car Lake
stuff so thanks for hanging out yeah we
got Hannah clir hanging out hey I'm
Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer for
sr.com I think it's hilarious that you
lead with I'm married to my college
sweetheart good family values I like to
start the show that way speaking of
family values one of my favorite moms is
in the room hi Libby hey I just want to
say this is Libby Emmons uh the Wall
Street Journal and the New York Times
have both already called it for Trump
they both said that Trump wins the New
Hampshire GOP Primary Nikki Haley we
we'll get into this but Nikki Haley is
going to use the numbers to say it is
not over even though they're not
Republicans voting for it right well she
is pretty um she does uh it's 54 to 45
so she's actually closer than people
thought she might be but it's and it's
18% of the votes are in so just like
with Iowa they called it way early y um
and this is Libby emans I'm with the
post millennial and uh I am sir.com with
timcast IRL and uh I hope you guys enjoy
the show be a good one all right let's
jump into this big news ladies and
gentlemen breaking post-millennial
Arizona GOP chair tried to bribe carry
Lake to not run for Senate leaked audio
he told Lake people were willing to put
their money where their mouth is I mean
the audio from this is ABS absolutely
nuts he says things like very powerful
people don't want you to run quote there
are very powerful people who want to
keep you out he told Lake in a
conversation last March Jeff DT told her
that the people were willing to put
their money where their mouth is this is
about defeating Trump and I think that's
a bad bad thing for our country she
replied these people people are corrupt
it's about control after Lake asked what
the powerful people wanted from her he
said they want you to stay out for 2
years I'll tell you what I can offer you
dot continued saying that there were
companies that could quote just put her
on the payroll to keep her out of the
senate race in the state when Lake
pushed back against the idea dwit asked
just say is there a number at which lake
cut in saying I can be bought that's
what it's about after insisting to Lake
that she could have a big voice in
politics and to take the offer of the
bribe Lake said that doing so would be
immoral and she wouldn't be able to look
at herself in the mirror the same ditt
insisted that Lake not tell anyone the
conversation happened now it's a
10-minute recording I don't want to play
everything but I I do want to play the
end part where he fears assassination
but I also want to point out in it he
mentions you can be a big personality
you can be a big voice it is about
defeating Donald Trump that's why they
want her out for for 2 years they want
Trump to lose after that then you can do
whatever you want let me play the last
portion of this and you can hear it for
yourself this stuff's
wild and okay let me refresh because x
video always does that and let's try
again what's about Dan santis getting D
santis in getting D santis is getting
Trump you're reading too deep into it
well let's see what happens maybe my
case will go through maybe they'll do
the right
thing I doubt I hope so I do too that's
my first goal yeah but they can't have
me in the governor's office cuz then way
you're going to root out some of this
corruption but again it's like you know
what it is the people don't get to
choose their elected officials unless
they're pre-approved by the
swamp and the swamp doesn't pre-approve
of me you need a strong party to help I
think you should go public with this and
then say hey these people don't want to
they don't want I turn my key in my car
and I
know I like then I turn my key in my car
and it
goes very powerful people sent this man
to bribe Carrie Lake into dropping out
because they want their pre-approved
candidates to be put in place and they
were going to pay her off so that she
would stop trying and this man says if
he goes public they will kill him it
with a Car Bomb now maybe he doesn't
literally mean car bomb but no no no no
no no then I turned my key in my car and
I think the implication is very very
obvious who are these powerful
people you I mean I'm going to be honest
with you guys we've been swatted several
times I know there are crazy people out
there people ask me if I'm ever
concerned about my safety and I always
say I'm less concerned with antifa than
I am with the crazy man who thinks I
broke into his house to steal all of his
spoons crazy people see you and they say
crazy things
I don't know anyone that I fear in the
immediate would try to kill me and I
don't I I mean I don't know if anyone
else here or anyone's been on the show
uh uh would would would in the immediate
say someone will kill me if I do a thing
you know what I mean yeah this is a guy
who's saying if I take this action they
will kill me he knows who they are he
knows the powerful people that have put
him up to this he knows that
someone sent him there and he thinks if
I cross them they'll kill me who's he
working
with well it's crazy you know it's
fascinating because we hear about you
know the Deep State the swamp all these
things we hear about these kind of
conversations taking place in politics
and then here we are we get a a
firsthand you know listen to this and so
it's one thing to hear about it I think
it's totally different when you actually
listen to the video and you hear that it
it kind of put it in a new context for
me and I'm sure many others out there as
well
yeah I mean I think it's only breeding
more distrust in the system that's
already there and I think in some ways
the political theater has gotten so
dramatic that people really equate it to
um what was that show that had Frank on
it and uh the and like all these DC sort
of s not like drum D house cars thank
you they think anything could happen but
then things like this come out and they
say oh it's all real it's all real uh
and they I think that's ultimately plays
into sort of this Elite group's uh Power
right they want you to be scared and
nobody ever came here and offered me a
bunch of money for any of this stuff
what's going on if this is what's going
on then we have a situation uh in
American politics that is a real problem
this is what we see in Russia we see
this kind of thing in Ukraine we see
this kind of thing where people are just
taken out you never hear from them again
in China if we have a situation where we
have political um operatives operating
behind the scenes to take people out if
they do a misstep then um I I think most
Americans would not be prepared for that
reality it sounds like Carrie Lake
recorded this because of the uh volume
of her voice and the volume of Jeff's
voice I'm wondering why it is it took
this long for it to get released you
know maybe she just now felt comfortable
doing it I don't know but it's it's it's
crazy too because this is Cary Lake this
isn't some no-name politician so the
fact that they felt comfortable enough
to go to someone like Carrie Lake and
have that conversation what are they
doing to other people that's just coming
in in desperate enough yeah desperate
enough that's that's a good that's why I
was saying in the intro to the show
tonight Civil War oh I'm you you you
better be careful because I'm gonna say
that a lot tonight with what's going
on they are so panicked and desperate
over what Carri Lake
represents she is America first she is
like she is like Trump and they're
probably thinking we nip this in the bud
now because if she actually advances
politically in this country we are
dealing with Trump once again this time
I'm I'll be completely honest K lake is
a bit more
uh what's the right word orthodox I
mean more poised maybe poised is maybe
the right word Trump is a is a Brash
celebrity character and they find ways
to use that to make him look bad but
Carri lake has Decades of television
experience and she comes off like top
tier political you know uh uh
highlevel like poised I suppose is
probably the best way to put it that is
something they will have they will
struggle with if she is running for
higher office if she is succeeding if
she's in the
Senate they're not going to be able to
stop her Trump trump gives them some
ammunition sometimes and they're going
as dirty as possible right now we know
what comes next for car Lake because in
conspiracy World it goes like this the
first thing they do is they ask you to
play ball hey you know we we really like
what you're doing why don't you come
work with us and then you say no I'm not
interested I don't like what you do then
they offer you money okay uh hey I got
this really great opportunity why don't
you take this job in this other place
when you refuse the money you know the
next step is the threats the next thing
that happens is maybe there's a car
accident you know family member has an
unfortunate turn and uh we would hate
for that to happen in the conspiracy
world that typically it goes with
recruitment failure bribery failure
threats of violence and assassination
and we've talked about that book uh was
a confessions of an economic Hitman
where he talks about on the larger scale
basically you go to Country you say you
are now part of our machine and our
Empire and if they say no then you offer
a bunch of money and say hey we'll give
you all these things they say no then
you stage a coup and remove them from
power and install someone who will do
what you want them to do it's like M
python sketch when he's like when
they're like that was a nice country
you've got here it'd be a shame
something happened to it yeah yeah so I
can only imagine with the release of
this audio and the man being recorded
saying effectively they will kill him
Carrie Lake man she needs she she got to
hire some security for her family they
weren't scared of her before I'm sure
they are now because I mean she says in
the audio like you're gonna have to kill
me you're not going to buy me you're not
going to pay me off and so she stood up
to this and so I think if they weren't
scared of her before they probably
definitely are now I fear they they will
MH I mean look the the the the sheer
desperation we are seeing from the
political Elites in this country is not
Beyond any of that right now
look the it is allegedly a conspiracy
theory that Epstein killed himself what
I mean is the mainstream media purports
that not a single real person in this
country believes EP killed himself no
and that interview with his brother was
really pretty shocking the the the the
the best line ever came from Chris reun
YouTube personality after it happened he
said he got into an Uber and the first
that happens is the driver turns around
and goes yo that guy didn't kill himself
nobody believes it Epstein himself and
his story was a conspiracy theory now we
know it's a fact gilan Maxwell's in jail
proven and they still haven't released
The Client List now that we're starting
to see beyond the curtain that these
things are happening now that we
actually got leaked audio of someone
trying to bribe car Lake I will say
right
now I'm just going to go ahead assume
all the rest of it true the funny thing
is people have been saying for some time
like two years now Conspiracy Theory
what Luke's got a shirt conspiracy
theories are just spoiler alerts right
six months six months it's true it
happened with all of them and it
happened in such quick succession you
know it was like getting whiplashed
everything that we were told was true
was a complete lie and now we see you
know you'll see a lot of conversations
bubbling up about about the way that
history has been taught and we're
suddenly realizing oh they taught us X Y
and Z about our national history and if
you dig into it it turns out those
things weren't true either I had a
professor in grad school who went
through um you know a whole bunch of
stuff he was like uh a Cuban Refugee as
a child and he was brought to Florida
and all this stuff and when things would
happen and we'd talk about history he'd
be like listen that's not how it
happened that's not how it happened at
all and he'd start explaining what it
looked like you know from his
perspective of having having lived
through it but we're seeing that all
over the place and it's just it's just
compounding it's hard to have any idea
um where to put your frot that's going
to be a solid ground and I think it's
changing forms too I instead of it just
being oh well this is how I was taught
this in high school I mean I remember
being taught stuff and being like this
obvious has bias to it but now it's also
sort of these uh historically based
miniseries that Netflix puts out and
they're actually slightly inaccurate but
that's where a lot of people are
learning kind of the gist of what happen
or they think the gist of what happened
during various points of time uh It
ultimately becomes uh plausible
deniability for anyone in the media who
gets to be like oh well we took some uh
creative Liberties here but you know we
don't have a strong enough and unbiased
education system to say here here is
what you need to know and you can watch
this and discern where they are taking
sort of a political leap and where this
is actually what happened the entire
concept of deconstruction that started
in philosophy has now just hit reality
and we're Decon rting everything every
day well and to your point about
everything kind of speeding up I feel
like they never expected president Trump
to win in 2016 it kind of thre a wrench
and their globalist agenda and their
everybody crying the next day like
literally sobbing and since that since
then everything has kind of just been in
overdrive speeding everything up and I
really think the left has overplayed
their hand with a lot of this though I
mean you know back to you know the the
the lockdowns and the mandates and all
that and what we saw from that where
parents were at home listening to what
was going on inside the classrooms and
all these other things and so I feel
like they almost they overplayed their
hand a lot of people have woken up to
this I mean if you go back seven eight
years not even 10 I mean 78 years and
tell everybody what took place over the
last few years they would say you're
crazy there's no way that's going to
happen yeah and here we are living in it
yeah I mean but you don't remember
people crying right because you're from
West Virginia which which had I mean
there really are states and cities that
had completely different experiences uh
Trump coming to office was something
that a lot of people celebrated very
intensely but you know you were what in
Brook at the time was actually it was it
was pretty crazy my friends were sobbing
and um I didn't vote for Trump but I
wasn't sobbing I was like oh now we have
a different president and I'm GNA
support the president because I'm an
American that's what I do well I I was
saying if Nikki Haley won tonight in New
Hampshire I'd be laughing my ass off
that would be hysterical it' be it' be
funny let's jump to this so uh we did
not lead with the New Hampshire primary
news despite the fact that some had
already called the race for Trump but
now we have officially numerous Outlets
have called New Hampshire for Donald
Trump that's not the big story however
of course Donald Trump won I don't see
any plausible scenar like there's no
reason for these primaries except
Democrats are trying to look man I have
so much disdain for these people that
scream M democracy while publicly
stating their intention to destroy our
institutions and even the concept of
democratic
representation meaning we democratically
elect a representative in our Republic
here's the story take a look at this so
there's Dave werman calling it for Trump
I want to play this clip Nuance bro has
the tweet from CNN Democrats are voting
for Nikki Haley tonight in New Hampshire
they're Biden supporters check this
Nikki Haley and why did you vote for
Nikki Haley uh it's a vote against Trump
um I think it would be better to have
her against Biden in the uh elections
than it would be Trump and her do you
consider yourself generally independent
Republican or Democrat uh Democrat so
when you Undeclared you voted for Nikki
Haley if it was Nikki Haley against Joe
Biden in a general election who are you
voting for Joe Biden what is the they
outright have no they have no Scruples
they have no
morals that that is like look I say the
banality of evil a lot but this is why
I've been I've been saying Civil War man
the process be damned to these people
Republicans keep playing this game of
look how magnanimous we are and the
Democrats keep laughing and trying to
knife them in the back here's a guy
who's saying your party's process means
nothing to me I will vote for the worst
candidate imaginable knowing Republicans
will not vote for so that when I vote
for Joe Biden I can
win what what form of government would
you call that if Joe Biden wins under
those circumstances what form of
government would this man call that it's
not democracy it's not a republic
I don't know what you'd call it I don't
either it's a system of governance where
one faction sabotages the other to
install a minority less pop like
massively unpopular candidate Joe
Biden's popular was his approval rating
in the 30s it's like 33% the last time I
looked it was like extremely this guy's
a fascist is it a fascist is it I I've
been sort of weighing is it
authoritarian is it totalitarian is it
fascist it literally is it's that's
exactly what it is it's the kind of
thing that uh people who have no faith
in the system of government that they
live in would do and no faith in Joe
Biden right he doesn't actually think
Joe Biden could match up against he
doesn't think yeah that's a really good
point so he's trying to say we have to
get Nikki Haley in there to help Biden
out because if it's a Biden Trump mashup
I mean he's not saying it but the the
subtext there is Biden will get defeated
by Trump there are a substantial number
of polls I think where Trump leads Biden
and the general yeah multiple out there
own it's amazing though how the left you
know they will they're so fascist all in
the name of anti-fascist and then you
know they're they're so intolerant all
in the name of Tolerance it's amazing
and fascinating how their minds work and
what they do and then you know Tim keeps
mentioning you know potential Civil War
and I I unfortunately have to agree
we're I think we're headed to that
direction hope we don't but you got to
think back uh but prior to the last
Civil War um that's when the Democrats
were removing people from the ballot
then they were removed Abraham Lincoln
from The Ballot leading up to the Civil
War now they're trying to do the same
thing president Trump that's a
misconception the idea of ballots being
publicly uh created and given out is a
new phenomenon that did not exist at the
time of the Civil War what happened was
the republ typically the parties would
create their ballots here are our
candidates give them out to people and
say you can basically sign it and and
drop in drop in the ballot this is who
you're voting for so it was a Partyline
ballot in I believe it was 10 Democrat
States Republicans did not issue ballots
because it wasn't so there were two big
reasons one they thought it was a waste
of time and energy you are not going to
win in slaves in these slave states that
oppos but a big a big factor was that
they were concerned that anyone who
supported the Republican Party in the
abolition of slavery in these states who
was seen carrying a ballot would
be shunned at worst beaten considering
we were in the in in The Bleeding Kansas
era where you had people like John Brown
shooting people in the face no one's
going to be seen carrying a a an Abraham
Lincoln ballot in in the southern states
so they were just not released by they
had the population so fearful partly to
to even do that because they were afraid
of what the other Democrats would would
do to them if they were to support
somebody who's in against slavery not a
single vote was cast for Abraham Lincoln
in the states that went on to secede
nobody would be caught dead doing it
because then you would be dead so it's
you know not the same as not having you
know having someone Ro from about but uh
because of that people have misconstrued
to Democrats removed them from
yeah they didn't have ballots back then
they had Party Line ballots so I I I
fact checked all that and it's uh I
think it's actually to a certain degree
more worrying as to you know I think it
was worse back then the fear that the
people are killing each other you know
you had Bleeding Kansas for seven years
where people were just showing up and
shooting each other John Brown walks to
a guy blasts him in the face just kills
him no questions unare that's crazy it
is where we're at now Aaron Danielson
was walking down the street Michael ryal
walked up to him and blasted him in the
chest two bullets killing him just
because yep and so it's it's fascinating
to me that we're in an era where these
stories could absolutely uh begin but
you know back to this
stuff Democrats are publicly admitting
there are no
elections that guy going on CNN and and
and and admitting this other Democratic
candidates saying that they've shut down
our primary so we can't can't
vote Marian Williamson is it and I think
Dean was it Dean Phillips pH Dean
Phillips of Minnesota that's right and I
got I got words Spit with this guy I I
don't trust him as far as I can throw
him Mar Williams and I like they're
saying why why are we being barred from
the primary why are we why is this not
being allowed because the unip party is
in control their fascist zealots like
that man are going to make sure there is
no election they will subvert it through
every loophole imaginable so that the
least popular candidate wins all while
screaming it's everybody else who's a
fascist well didn't they also steal the
the primary from Bernie Sanders back in
2016 yeah so I mean there just nothing
they they've done this before thing too
is like they refused to the Democrats
refused to go into New Hampshire they
tried to push them to do South Carolina
instead and then when it looked like
there were going to be contenders they
launched a Right End campaign even
though Biden's not on the ballot and uh
you know that's incredibly rude too
that's like I definitely take your cake
can eat it too situation um and Biden
has 73% of that Phillips has 20% right
now so with like how much in I mean I'm
looking at 31% 31% so as for this
Phillips guy he's got this video where
he's complaining to the Press saying you
won't cover my story you're not asking
the right questions he's he's like Biden
can't win I am trying to do this why
won't you tell the right story Laura
lummer shows up mhm she had showed up to
a Marian Williamson event yep totally
respectfully saying I agree with you you
are right it is wrong what they're doing
they threw her out yep so this guy wants
to claim oh the media they won't cover
my story well now you've got someone
with a massive platform who is not here
to berate you but to actually amplify
your message and you throw her out and
it's because they're like oh well we
want to make sure we look good to the
press the press that won't actually
these people are are and then maryan
Williamson gave her a microphone to
basically and you could see Laura wasn't
there to to cause any issues she was
truly there as a journalist this is why
we like Marion Williamson yeah Mar Mar
Williamson was like oh welcome yes
please there you go have fun and they
they agreed and Marion Williamson was
like I thought you're going to ask me
about how they're doing this that and
just went off on them and I'm like good
but
like this like people like Dean Phillips
he wants to win the Democratic primary
what he really wants is for the
corporate press to acknowledge Him
that's what he's complaining about Laura
L doesn't count he doesn't care about
her he doesn't care about what her
followers or the average person might
think he wants the New York Times to
acknowledge that he's running and he's
so frustrated I don't understand why
they won't perhaps it's because your
party is run by fascists and they are
corrupt
unsurprising but that's what you get and
this is where we're headed right now so
you know my view of this is if
if people have said this could be the
last election in fact we have a a book
right here look this just because we
have all these things just lying around
hey shout out to Steven Marsh who gets
cited on this show so often despite the
fact we agree on a lot of things he's uh
researched and written about Civil War
he wrote a book with Andrew Yang called
the last election I think he's wrong
though this isn't the last election the
last election was 2016 oh you think so
you think we already saw the last
legitimate election I think you could
technically argue that the last election
was 2012 interesting agreed
2016 they Democrats claimed it was
stolen and Russia stole it and then they
they tried to destroy Donald Trump false
impeachments they claimed it was stolen
for four years the whole time when they
do it though it's okay when they do it
did we actually have an election in did
we actually have an election in 2016 if
half half the country's political forces
disrupted the administration 2020 well
the right doesn't think that was
legitimate did we have an election then
no 2016 was disputed by the Democrats
20120 disputed by the Republicans and
right now Democrats are actively
admitting they are actively sabotaging
and admitting to sabotaging the 2024
election in every way from the
Democratic primary to the Republican
primary they are saying to our faces
they are going to burn the system to the
ground there's no election well did you
see at at his uh his uh like Pro
abortion themed rally in Virginia today
Joe Biden opened up by going hello
Virginia and hello to the real governor
of Virginia Terry mcaffe I don't know if
I'm saying his name right but it's it's
like if if Trump had done that in a
state where it had been a contentious
election everyone would be like election
deny her and I know there are some
Republicans doing that now mcalli thank
you I was like maffy it's like when I'm
writing it I switch all the letters
around shout out to Chris Carr for being
a great editor uh but there is this
moment where it's sort of more Brazen
it's okay when we do it and it seems to
be escalating and this is the same rally
where there were like 14 Interruption by
Pro Palestine protesters during I mean
there were four in the first five
minutes so it's there is Discord all
around but there's definitely a a moment
in my opinion where people who vote
Democrat are sort of looking at the
party and saying do we believe you and
do we represent you and do you actually
know what we want out of you and I think
in some ways the interesting part about
Trump's candidacy is it was a reckoning
of there is a huge population in this us
who wants certain things like border
border security they want you to address
the fentanyl crisis they want you to
take on certain issues that to be fair
the Republican uh sort of Old Guard just
didn't take seriously because it didn't
seem to affect them they didn't take it
seriously and I think the um the
American leftists didn't take it
seriously they didn't think that uh you
it's it's like that we have a total
disconnect in again the nature of ity
here and we do in so many cases you have
a bunch of people in the United States
saying that men are women that's just
insane it's obviously insane you have
Joe Biden saying that the border is
closed and that Congress needs to do
something to act to to close the border
but everyone knows full well that
Congress has absolutely no power right
now right I mean even if Congress passed
something the Senate's not going to take
it up Joe Biden would not sign any bill
that actually closed the Border it just
would not happen but I I will say this
though um the Democrats and I I despise
what they stand for but they they they
actually fought for what they believe in
the they have shut this country down
before and you know we have a bunch of
in my opinion spinless jelly back Ranos
representing Us in Congress right now
who are just can you just say that again
spinless jelly back Ros and they can
they continue to just give them whatever
they want instead of holding the line
it's like our our country's being
invaded right now who cares if we end up
shutting the Border down in order to to
secure funding for that or to to close a
border in some some way let's jump to
story from the post-millennial Texas
installs more razor wire on Eagle Pass
border after Supreme Court said Biden
could remove it Texas will not back down
from our efforts to secure the Border in
Biden's absence you I was thinking about
Civil War earlier today and uh Fort
Sumpter the start of the Civil War we
say Fort Sumpter and then there's the uh
First Battle of Bull Run or the Battle
of Manasses and I'm thinking I wonder if
in a 100 years they're going to say the
first battle at Eagle Pass or they're
going to say eagle pass was the start of
the second Civil War I don't know you
know it could just we can't see the
future it'll be hindsight being 20120
100 years from now they're going to look
back and who knows they could say the
2020 election they could say January 6
they could say a lot of things but right
now what we're looking at is an
escalation of what is effectively a Fort
Sumpter esque moment I said it was
literally Fort Sumpter and Ian got mad
and he said no it's figuratively cuz
they're not actually there and I'm like
no I am saying it is literally the
circumstances of Fort Suter in this
instance the federal government has
asserted its jurisdiction on a border
however it is facilitating criminal
actions Customs and Border Protection
agents are committing
crimes serious humanitarian violations
and criminal activities Texas is trying
to stop them deploying armed
soldiers I think people need to
understand it's fascinating when I talk
about Civil War several years ago and
people are like you really think there's
going to be like armed soldiers marching
against the federal government it turns
out Texas deployed armed National Guard
to push out the feds who have went to
the Supreme Court asserted their
jurisdiction here and Texas said f off
anded what does the federal government
do well as long as long as Texas is
going to hold the line which I think is
awesome and I support them doing that I
think that we need to encourage more red
states to to follow suit like West
Virginia for instance Ohio Kentucky
sending the National Guard as well to to
give them some
you think we should send a National
Guard to Texas uh well Texas's national
guard is there I believe that they're
going to hold the line on this issue of
our country being invaded right now I
would love to see West Virginia send
ours in there to send back up such a
huge escalation yeah well I think that
that's warranted at this you have no
idea what I would do if I was the
governor of West Virginia same that's
what I'm if I was in charge I would I
would I'm not talking 10 people to get a
headline I would send the national guard
down there and I would encourage my stat
govern I would I would I would instruct
the West Virginia National Guard to
seize the CB facility over at 340 we
know for a fact CBP agents they're on
camera smuggling humans children
children sex trafficking B it it is it
is insane to me there was a video I I
showed earlier where someone actually
interviewed one of these agents as
they're facilitating human smuggling
working with
cartels and they go well it's crazy
they're letting them in and the guy I I
I don't know who actually produced the
video he says it basically it's strange
because when they say they're being
allowed in it's CBP who's doing it now
there's a facility over in West Virginia
not too far away from here a massive CBP
fac I didn't know this I didn't know
that right over there yeah and I'm
wondering how could anyone work I don't
care if you're if you're slinging coffee
yeah we know for a fact that CBP agents
are engag in human trafficking right now
working children working with cartels
breaking the law and are staging they
are the they are the villains the bad
guys fighting against the sovereignty
and the law and there are people in West
virgin you're like it's my job yeah it's
my job oh well you're a scumbag but I
think this question of how will we
remember this period of history is
really interesting like you were saying
are we going to look back this and say
is this the Battle of eal pass to me it
reminds me more of the standoff at Ruby
Ridge right there was a time when we saw
the federal government being aggressive
and we waited to see what would happen
in this case Ruby Ridge was a handful of
people but I'm I'm what I'm saying is
it's interesting to look back and say
you know at the time the federal
government said we're justified in what
we're doing and we look back and say
like was that the correct thing to do
will we look back at the border people
who don't necessarily see illegal
immigration as a problem and will they
look back at it and say yeah will they
say oh we should have let the razor wire
stay oh we oh we know why Texas is we
understand this now because we live with
the consequences of those actions well
and this is why this is not a time for
weak politicians I mean it really isn't
this is a time where we need some some
patriots to get involved in politics we
have too many politicians in politics
because a politician's not going to send
in the National Guard from West Virginia
Ohio or Kentucky but a patriot someone
like Carrie Lake because she was in
charge of Arizona right now I guarantee
you their National Guard would be doing
the same thing right now at the Arizona
border one of her campaign PR I I think
West Virginia state governance should
immediately have an investigation into
the CBP facility yes they should be
subpoenaing records they should be
getting warrants they should be going
through all their documents to what
degree is is the CBP in West Virginia
working with or facilitating the
trafficking that's happening at the
border because we know and I'm wondering
how much this affects West Virginia we
know that CBP is bringing these people
to airports to uh to uh Bus Charters and
having them sent around the country in
an interview one of these guys says
they're given a was like A2 or $3,000
gift card and they're given
accommodation and places to sleep I I I
do not believe West Virginia is not one
of these destinations I think it is
extremely likely these people are being
sent here to the extent that they can be
due to infrastructure I think the fact
that we know and I've seen on video and
you can go down there and witness it for
yourself that CBP agents are engaged in
human trafficking that's more than
enough probable cause for the legal
apparatus of West Virginia to go in with
a bunch of guys in in police jackets and
start ripping through those documents to
figure out what it is CBP is doing and
why they're doing it I think anybody who
works for CBP at this point who hasn't
resigned over this is a scumbag well say
if our West Virginia elected legislators
and elected officials are not going to
do that then they should everyone be
primaried and kicked out of office
because if they don't have the courage
to step up and do that when it's
happening in our state because they they
love everybody loves to sit back and say
oh this is happening over another this
is happening I didn't know this was
happening in West Virginia this is crazy
to me because I'm on the other we don't
know what is happening well I know but I
mean that there was a facility there I
should say I didn't know this and so I
agree I I think at the very least there
should be some proper investigations
into that I mean we know there's 80
5,000 missing children that we know of
right now well and there's there's got
to be more than that right because
there's a rule and this was again this
was like a judge who said that uh um it
was like a you know the Flores
settlement this whole thing so basically
like a judge said that children need to
be released unaccompanied miners need to
be released they can't be held without
you know for like very long time or
whatever and they were very displeased
with the the conditions that children
were being held in so it was like okay
the children have to be released
children would be released there'd be
sponsors Etc DHS doesn't even know who
the sponsors are there's no vetting and
then after and this was like in when was
the Flores thing it was like in the 90s
or something like that but it keeps
coming up and then Obama took the florz
settlement and was like okay well um
we're going to have to separate the kids
from the adults and that's how family
separation started you separate the kids
from the adults so that the kids would
be released but you wouldn't be
releasing the adults and then this you
know it comes up again and it turns out
now you have to release the adults with
the children if they come across and it
creates this golden ticket situation and
you don't even know who the adults are
and you have like so many reporters have
gone down and reported on the border
showing that people uh before they cross
the border they'll ditch their ID
documents yeah they show them laying
there around around the Border people
need to remember your tax dollars are
paying for our own government to you're
aiding and abetting the child sex
traffing of
children when you look at the effect and
the impact you can only start to believe
that this is what they wanted to happens
absolutely they they must want a huge
cartel backed child sex ring happening
in the United States they must want lots
of our citizens to be dying from fenel
overdoses they must want that they must
want the destruction of our show that
they they were literally like think
about it at one point they were saying
all the the Border The Border's closed
they were just you know saying it was
blond but then Texas it starts building
their own you know their own barriers
and the Joe Biden Administration the
Democrats are actively suing to open it
back up every time so they can't even
hide from this anymore and pretend that
it's not thatc well Congress has to do
something but we're going to sue so we
have the right to do it and I would veto
any bill that they're literally fighting
to open the border and and and allow our
country to be invaded like they're on
they're there there's no way around it
they the bad guys here are the CBP
agents themselves yeah they're the Nazi
guards and I say this right now I will
lighten up a little bit to the CBP
agents that may hear this you know I
assume if you're just now finding out
like you work let's say you work in the
facility over off 340 and you're filing
paperwork and you do accounting stuff
and you have no idea what's going on
okay I think it's fair that upon
discovery of what the B Administration
is doing you resigning is the noble
thing to do for those that know exactly
what's going on and what's being done
and either are complicit in involved in
it or knowing it's happening don't care
and say leave me out of it I'll take my
paycheck I I I will say there is nothing
I pray for more right now than to see
these people rot in prison for the rest
of their
lives you can come to me and you can
offer me an infinity pool a Ferrari and
a great Mansion I'll say I want none of
those things you come to me and say
we'll give you one thing I say I want
those people arrested I want them in
jail I want each and every one of these
CBP agents that's down there on the
boorder arrested by the Texas National
Guard and Texas state troopers and lock
up and I want them to cry and say but
why and it's because you're a human
Smuggler you
scumbags these people are are are abject
evil they are quite literally the I
should say figuratively the demons in
the devil's Army I mean that
figuratively perhaps some people believe
it literally this this smuggling
operation that we are seeing that has
Eric Adams in panic Democrats freaking
out people in Chicago in uproar their
schools are being taken over and it is
these SE agents on the border with
smiles on their faces saying I don't
know I'm getting paid just doing my job
just doing my I'm getting paid it's
great I get my paycheck hey man I don't
care about what's happening to this
country I don't care what happens to you
I don't care how many people die I don't
I don't care how many people die trying
to cross through these deserts they are
getting paid and that's all they care
about I hope if anything and I I don't
believe this will happen but I really
hope that when Donald Trump gets elected
one of the first things he does is sends
federal agents to arrest all of the
agents that were involved in the human
smuggling operations it's the first
thing he does when he begins his Mass
wave of deportations he says the first
thing we have to do is stop the human
smuggling operation and those who who
facilitated it we know for a fact who it
was because their names are all in our
books and so I'm going to make sure I do
everything in my power that I Lobby
every politician I know that I speak
with anyone I know who's working in
government and say I expect these men to
be in prison
now to be fair I expect criminal charges
to be brought against them the evidence
to be be presented in court of law and
for the sentence to be uh
um warranted for the crime committed and
I don't know how many years do you think
you get for human smuggling I'm going to
look it up not enough yeah probably not
maybe just a couple hundred hours
community service oh yeah something like
the weed psychosis lady no but look you
know there's going to be some guy who's
23 and he's like I don't know my boss
just told me to be a human and I'm like
okay I'm looking forward to the day you
cry and you cry as you're being ripped
from your home and and thrown into the
back some of these people should be
charged with treason for aiding and
abetting the not Tre it's sedition or
sedition do you think some of these
people should be charged with with some
of that I know that's a little bit
different than the traffing correct so
the higher ranking agents who are aware
of what's going on yes they're involved
in a s seditious conspiracy I think the
agents On the Border who are just told
hey be a human Smuggler like they know
they're trafficking humans there's no
way they don't know this they know so
that would be a human IGN smuggling uh
non-citizens into the US it looks like
it's punishable by up to 20 years in
prison great that's a good amount of
time it could be extended to life if
someone dies as a result well there been
a lot that's died and there are already
stories that we've pulled up where
people have been criminally charged by
the doj for transporting within the
country criminal aliens so there were
two soldiers two uh uh enlisted guys who
didn't smuggle These Guys across the
border they were just transporting them
knowing they were getting paid to do it
and they went to prison that was several
years ago I think that was during the
Trump trump years now the Biden
Administration ordered these guys to be
criminal I'm sorry dude if your boss
comes to you and says Roba bank and you
go I guess I have to do it I look
forward to seeing you in prison I just
now real quick the high-ups in the Biden
Administration seditious conspiracy 100%
lock them up I just think this is the
point where people who work as border
agents for the federal government should
consider leaving for you know to be a
border uh agent joining the Texas
National Guard they should move to the
state level because it seems at least in
this case like the states are willing to
do something the federal government
government isn't which is to defend the
rights of the people in their
communities uh I get that the idea of
being like you can't just ask them to
leave their jobs is scary I understand
that but they are in a specialized
career where as far as I know it's
chronically underst staffed at the state
and federal level so they could leave
they could change they at least be
whistleblowers no no no no no no no no
no no no you come to me and you say Tim
I can't quit my job because my kids need
food and I say okay what's your job I
work at the Cracker Factory and I I want
to support Trump my company super woke
and I'm scared if I speak up I'll get
fired how am I going to feed my family I
say well that's that's a tough position
I understand I do uh do your best make
money protect your family you come to me
and say I can't quit my job my kid needs
food I go what's your job I'm a human
Smuggler I say I look forward to seeing
you locked up I look forward to the day
your children are crying as they are
ripped from your arms as you were thrown
in the back of a police van for being a
human Smuggler you do not get to live in
the comfort of your own home as a human
Smuggler you are you are these these are
some of the darkest and most evil
actions a person could engage in and
these guys are like well my boss told me
to do it I don't care but you zero
sympathy lock them up you could also
have a boss on a state level that's like
no no more razor wire don't do that like
you're choosing to work for the federal
government where this is the order
you're getting there are states that
that wouldn't make you do this sure quit
you're if you're in CBP quit right now
if you work for the customs and board of
protection and you are getting a
paycheck knowing what they are doing and
you say yeah but my kid needs food I
want you in prison I don't care I have
no sympathy whatsoever I don't care what
job you're doing you are facilitating
this when we have the majority of people
in this country citing immigration as
the principal issue when you have
Democrats and Republicans in up when
Biden laughs and says the border is not
secure knowing what he's doing and
you're like I'm part of an organization
that operates human smuggling operation
and I'm like stop don't do that and you
go but my kids need food okay well bank
robbers kids need need food and when
they say I robbed a bank cuz I wanted to
feed my family we still put them in
prison I think that's I I think a that's
a reasonable point it it does remind me
a lot of the you know the the Nazi
guards who were just doing their jobs we
still dragged a bunch of them back from
Argentina or wherever and put them on
trial at the ha didn't we do that some
point you got look yourself in the
mirror and ask if what you're doing is
moral or not I mean that's what it this
is everything we're really dealing with
in our country in my opinion is
spiritual warfare we got a lot of good
versus evil going on in our country and
and people to Tim's point you know they
make excuses and say well I'm just doing
this or I've got to do it for this
reason and but what you're doing is one
of the most cruel unjust things you
could ever do which is aiding and a
betting and actually participating in
smuggling not just humans but I mean
children this is absolutely despicable
and and I love your outrage and I share
it with you I I'm you know we had uh
Michael Mouse came on the show a long
time ago and he said that I'm
paraphrasing but the actions of
politicians are letters to Santa without
the police yeah it is the of and and so
I've had a lot of people try to make
this play politicians come in here like
oh no no you can't blame the cops
they're good people it's the leadership
that's bad I say I don't care about
leadership Bill DeBlasio can go out in
the middle of the street Buck Naked
screaming into the wind for all I care
it's meaningless but if he does it and
the cops then protect him while he's
doing it now that's the problem the
individual officers who are engaging in
this activity this goes back to when
DeBlasio stole taxpayer funds to paint
black lives matter front of Trump's uh
fth Avenue building and then used I
think it was like 27 police officers to
protect it so stealing from the public
coffers for a political purpose for
personal gain and those cops had Smiles
on their faces while they they did what
they were told that's that's that's
that's policing in New York City now I
mean what we're seeing at Eagle Pass and
not just Eagle Pass but in Arizona and
New Mexico is shocking what is it an
80-year-old guy how old's that old man
uh I think he's 82 but I'll double check
cartel activity on his property he
defends himself they arrest him they
lock him up that's why that's why I'm
I'm I'm like no there's there's no
sympathy at this point it's not just
about one thing happening one time it's
about the state of the country and where
we are right now where you defend your
property you go to prison 74 sorry he
was 74 years old just like the M him so
dramatically remember the mclusky they
had to get a pardon just for standing
outside of their home being like don't
you guys come in people broke in ripped
the fence down and they branded firearms
and they got in trouble for it and
that's the thing though like if I I
really believe if the American people
thought that they were able to go to the
border and help Texas National Guard
defend the border right now and secure a
border you would see American Patriots
who would willingly go do this but they
can't because they're going to get
thrown in prison if they were to even
think about doing that they even if they
went down there at all I mean they're
threatened to arrest people for holding
a video camera and videotaping could you
imagine yeah could you imagine if
someone was down there saying we're not
going to let you in what they would do
to these people well isn't it crazy that
Texas had to make had to make a law that
illegally entering
Texas from an international border was
illegal yeah that's just insane they
started arresting people the other day
the Federal Government tried stopping
them yeah well and and there's there's
really Technically when you get into the
the roles of the federal government
they're really limited on what they're
supposed to do they've gotten way too
big for their britches and and
everything but one of the few things are
yeah but one of the things they're
supposed to do is actually secure the
Border you have so many few true jobs
and you won't
and they're supposed to protect States
from Invasion what is it like yeah
they're supposed to definitely do that
it's interesting looking at the Supreme
Court um and giving them the benefit of
the doubt right like let's say we could
give them the benefit of the doubt uh if
you look at some of their other cases
recently or if you look at the oral
arguments in Chevron the other day uh
the EPA versus West Virginia even dos if
you look at these things what they're
doing is they are handing power back to
the legislators they're taking it away
from the court courts they're saying you
know and if you look at this situation
they're saying the court this Lower
Court does not have the right to decide
what the federal government can do in
this border situation so you wonder like
perhaps the Texas state legislature
should start taking this stuff up you
know and perhaps Congress should look
into impeaching some of these Supreme
Court Justices were doing I know I would
I'm tell right now day one impeaching
may orcus it doesn't make any sense that
they're not and it doesn't make sense
that they're not um yeah that is
interesting let let me pull this story
from the post-millennial US voters say
immigration not inflation is a top
priority Harvard Harris poll so uh posto
reports more voters are pointing to
immigration as their top issue instead
of inflation as the country goes in the
2024 election a Harvard caps Harris poll
of 2,346 registered voters that was
released on Monday the survey found 35%
of respondents had immigration as their
top concern and 32% named the topic of
inflation immigration has jumped seven
points from last month I spent the
holidays in Chicago they're trying to
build camps sad what do you want to call
them inter tournament camps I don't
think we should call them detention
camps for illegal migrants IL
concentration camps you could call them
concentration camps uh in New York Eric
Adams is putting a curfew on them yeah
on the on the illegals on the illegal on
the shelters that that house the illegal
immigrants so when when people say
inflation the only issue there is that
these people aren't aware of immigration
correct because if you go to someone
who's jenzy and they were like the rent
is too damn High I say okay what's your
apartment say it's it's 70 square ft I
spent
$2,000 I respond did you know that New
York is taking illegal immigrants and
giving them hotel rooms with full
bathrooms kitchenet and a bed the entire
Hotel utilities everything's taken care
of while you struggle to pay your bills
y immigration is an inflationary issue
absolutely 100% And and we should be we
should impeach May orcus it's it's
absolutely mind-blowing that we don't
our Congress who is controlled by the
house and or the the Republicans control
the house and they don't even have
enough backbone to impeach mayorcas
right now this is mindblowing they
should all be we should be impeaching we
should be impeaching Joe Biden
absolutely you know you know what the
name of the game is you know why like a
state like West Virginia would not try
to investigate
CBP how much in federal dollars does
West Virginia receive exactly what it is
so so it's so unfortunate some of these
smaller red States balance their budget
on the backs of the federal dollar
coming in that's really one of the
things they hold hostage over the small
states when it comes to um like the
transgender issue in schools and the
education stuff they
give Department yeah but the Department
of Education that's why I'm proponent of
getting rid of the Federal Department of
Education well quite frankly I would
abolish all the three-letter agencies
and return to power back to the states
and the local communities where they
belong the Department of Agriculture was
interesting because they were saying uh
if you don't have these uh lessons about
whatever gender Theory ideology will cut
the money for uh subsidized lunch which
is then the and the bathrooms they had
the bathrooms and the sport and then
they were like which obviously means
that the the headlines would be like
Republicans vote against funding lunches
for kids in need like they know what
they're doing and they're being
dishonest about it and still
conservative small rural States pay the
price I will say I do think conservative
media got a good handle on that story
right from the beginning and said you
know uh Biden Administration is
threatening free school lunches for kids
over letting boys into girls' bathrooms
I thought we did a good job with that
the other thing too the Department of
Agriculture is a disaster they had this
whole thing where they were prioritizing
Farm loans for minority farmers and you
had a group of white Farmers sued and
they were like this is discriminatory
and you had a judge actually say you
can't fix current you can't fix past
discrimination with current
discrimination and Tom vilac was you
know handed his his loan papers back or
whatever but he should be impeached also
he's a disaster as well just nobody
really pays that much attention to the
Department of Agriculture because
there's so many I mean you were making
this point too it has gotten so big that
people don't realize that it's a
Department of Agriculture that oversees
school lunches or you know what I mean
they don't always know what the scope of
every agency is and part of that is
because we've had so many different
agencies that have been reshuffled and
reorganized that we can't keep track of
it and I'm sure they can't either which
these AG abolish them not not just
defund them abolish these three-letter
agencies return the power back to the
States back to the local communities
back to you and me and we the people
because when it's at a localized level
accountability there's no account we
have a bunch of unelected bureaucrats
right now sitting in DC running our
country behind the scenes with no
accountability how many staff people
just sitting there like ordering lunch
every
day yeah just hanging out think about
office life think how expensive office
there bureaucrats like Crossing off the
calendar being like I'm so much closer
to my government pension which you know
people need jobs people need to work I'm
not criticizing them for that vations
ultimately why is this job available at
all well not only that my answer to most
of these people is name one thing that
the federal government does better than
the private sector yeah well that's a
good question right I don't I can't name
I can't name anything that the
government does better than what the
private sector would do yeah yeah I
don't see that hold on waste money yeah
waste money we're good at that Absol I
gotta be honest like the private sector
is really good at wasting money but the
government man at least there's
accountability there shareholders and
well because it's not their money and
they haven't earned it so you don't feel
anything for losing money if you didn't
earn that money it's just nothing right
at private you have to eventually say
your shareholders like so keep losing
money and with the government they can
say we lost money but no worries you'll
just give us more and we'll raise taxes
if we need imagine imagine being so bad
at managing money that you steal every
citizen in the country's money and
you're steal $34 trillion in debt that
is just insane you almost have to
attempt to do that they literally still
everyone's money we didn't stop at 34
and yeah we're 30 something trillion
dollars in debt we're more than 34 now
because it just keeps going
Up's here we go we go guys listen though
this is the this is the thing the
spending originates in the House
Republicans have control of the house we
have to as I'm a republican as
Republicans we have to own this at this
point another uh you know CR we have a
bunch of weak spess spinless jelly back
rhos representing Us in Congress right
now because they want to just kick the
can down the road and sign another CR
and allow all these things that's
currently happening to continue
happening instead of holding the line MH
that's what it comes down to when you to
run for Congress you ultimately decided
that you have to go to the Federal
Government Federal level to cut off
problems that are affecting West
Virginia rather than run for State
because you did hold State and and
unfortunately the the federal government
has gotten so big that it does affect
every and I don't want that I want I
want to get rid of all that power it's
centralized at the federal level and
return it back to the States where
there's accountability once again there
are there are limited roles a federal
government supposed to have one of them
is securing our border and they can't
even do the one thing like not they
can't but instead of worrying about all
these other issues not part of their
their role they should worry about the
few things that they're supposed to do
which which is that and you know I think
that our national SEC the spending right
now and our everything you know our debt
is really a matter of national security
at this point I mean honestly think
about the the interest rate alone is
going to be like a trillion dollars a
year on interest alone coming up this is
crazy yeah they just print more money
until the economy implodes and I think
that's honestly I think that we're at
the point maybe that's what they're
trying to do they realize that there's
no going back at this point so they're
just and go like an acceleration and
then think about all the money we're
sending to Ukraine and our own countes
being invaded we're sending money to
other countries to to secure their
border well and we're sending money all
over the world for really stupid things
as well like you know gender research in
India and all of these different kinds
of things uh that don't make any kind of
sense at all we send money to the UN and
then the UN goes out there and tell
tells all of these nations again you
know I hate to harp on it even though I
do all the time the UN goes out there
and the World Health Organization and
they go out there and they tell
everybody that they have to have more
gender equity and trans it's so sad that
we sent a single dollar to any of those
organizations it's it's absolutely
ridiculous think about they still our
money we're in debt $34 trillion in debt
they still our money and they're sending
it over to these these organizations who
quite frankly hate us M they do yeah
they do hate us we're and so to like
most of the illegal immigrants coming in
hate us yep you know what is what is it
that they think they're going to get
here they're waving the flag of another
country as they're coming across our
bord c I mean like if you know anyone
who's taking a citizenship like you are
ultimately supposed to pledge loyalty to
America you're supposed to adopt the
values you're supposed to become
patriotic on some level right and that's
not the bar when you migrate illegally
right when you should be the goal we
don't we don't have assimilation going
on at all in fact we have you know awoke
Democrat uh powerful officials who are
saying that people shouldn't assimilate
because America is bad and their their
own National Heritage and whatever is
better than America in which case like
like go home go home have people in
Congress who feel that way we have
elected Democrats in Congress who
literally openly say they hate our
country I yeah like what all of the AOC
people right her whole little crew yeah
but that means that their voters hear
that me their voters hear that message
and resonate with it right well they
vote they vote for that they want them
they want that to
be why would you pick a to me I just
can't I can't rra my mind around it why
you would pick an elected official that
is like I hate it here I don't believe
in anything I don't like these values
actively think everything is bad and
therefore I will not work for its
betterment and its security like you are
picking instability do how can you be
okay with that how can you inflict that
on your neighbors it must be what they
want well I think I think that our
school system has really unfortunately
indoctrinated a lot of the young people
into believing a lot of this they they
they they really do not like America a
lot of the young college age kids right
now we taught them to hate us and and
and well because our our public
universities in in particular have been
basically transformed into creating
social justice Warriors and that's what
they're doing and that's why I think
that we need to withhold funding from
these universities if they want to push
the social justice Warriors and push
people to get our countes withhold that
money you can become a public or a
private university and fund it yourself
if you want to want to do those sorts or
shut them down or shut them down and
completely I agree but I'm just saying
and I don't want to pay back the student
loans either I think that the
universities should pay back the student
loans with their own
endowments unilaterally just doing it
he's just doing it even though Supreme
Court said no yep and we should stop
issuing that what does that mean for
Texas like this is what I never get
about student loans which is that it's a
bad system we talk about constantly it's
it's handcuffing yourself to debt as you
launch into adulthood it's not a good
return on investment for anyone if you
were a small business as an 18-year-old
saying please give me money for this
can't get it you wouldn't get it and yet
we're still like well it's okay Biden's
going to forgive them and then we'll
just keep issuing them so we pretend
like we want to eradicate this problem
we being the federal government right
now by forgiving the debt but also we're
actually perpetuating the problem
because we still give out student loans
that we know are bad it it just just
makes no sense and people are expected
to say like I'm not going to use any
sort of critical analysis to say this is
a broken system that's meant to entrap
me well before I got into real estate
like I was I was a school teacher that's
kind of what I went to school for what
year did you teach um what year what
grade you mean or I taught fourth grade
and then I taught some sixth grade okay
but um the thing is that's crazy about
um what's going on in our school system
right now it it would be less scary for
me if I thought these teachers were
pushing this social justice stuff from a
malicious standpoint the scariest part
about all this is they've been
indoctrinated into believing it's their
role and their moral duty to overstep
the parents and step in and push these
issues that's the scary part about this
whole thing well and they learned all
that in the grad schools that are funded
by the federal government that we should
shut down cor absolutely that's the
scary part honestly but so do you think
that people are able to reconcile uh
their own sense of self with the lack of
Morality In America I feel like
ultimately one of the things that drives
uh an abandonment of traditional
American values is the internal
selfishness that people are really
cultivating these days yeah I definitely
understand where you're coming from on
that and I just think that we are
underestimating how uh young minds you
know 21 and under specifically you know
25 and under how they can be manipulated
in some way I mean when you're into an
environment where someone's placed in an
authority authoritative level like a
professor and they're telling you that
this is you know this is what you're
supposed to do as a teacher or whatever
else and you start to believe that and
then you turn on TV and billboards and
everywhere it's all around you all the
celebr that you once again up on this
platform and I think that they've just
been manipulated I really do and and I
think that people are waking up to it
though I mean I I tell everyone at on
the ballot in 2024 we have uh Joe Biden
with uh tyranny and uh you know poverty
or you can have freedom and prosperity
with President Trump yeah but I also
wonder if it's enough of an anecdote
like being awake to it and actually
changing the way you live and the way
you approach your your life is it enough
to turn turn turn The Tides I don't know
I I really don't know that answer
because I don't know if there's enough
people who would be willing to do that
and then unfortunately there's a lot of
conservative teachers out there who are
afraid to speak not just teachers and a
lot of these they're afraid to speak out
though and I tell everyone look you know
what happened to myself and and everyone
else involved in January 6 specifically
they were using us as examples to put
fear into the American people and I
think we have to remember that our
rights do not come from the government
our rights come from God our creator and
the Constitution was written to prevent
the government from infringing on our
natural god-given rights and so if we
willingly give up our free speech out of
fear we've already lost this battle and
we're in a battle right now for the
future of this country let me jump to
the story from cnr.com Pro Biden Super
PAC to spend $1 million on Tik Tock
influencers the pack may have already
violated some of Tik tok's policies you
know we got enough problems as it is
with Tik Tok and their algorithm and all
that and now quote the effort is part of
a larger Democratic strategy to lure
young voters into Battleground States
who uh in Battleground States who polls
show are increasingly critical of Biden
whether over his age or issues like a
stand towards Israel Biden's re-election
campaign itself is amping up its work
with social media influencers in 2024
though those Partnerships are currently
unpaid Daniel wessell a Biden campaign
spokesperson told Politico the White
House team separately is also flexing
its creator game throwing its first ever
influencer Christmas party last December
so there's this guy who made a video
where he was he his his uh Tik Tok he's
got 400,000 followers and he just yells
so he's always complaining about
something and he yells and he's
complaining about the economy he
recently made a video where he said he
was contacted by someone claiming to be
in the Democratic party who offered him
$50,000 for a pro Biden post wow and
post one post wow and he said as
somebody who sells shout outs and reads
like 50
$50,000 is a lot of money for a single
post
right
so the powers that be are ready to drop
I would assume more than $1 million on
uh getting people to claim Biden's the
right choice I remember back in 2016
there were a lot of high-profile
personalities on YouTube that for some
reason were just in favor of Joe Biden
and we are like why but here's here here
we go I'm wondering what the Republicans
have to counter this I was wondering
that too that was my first question is
what is the RNC spending on social media
influencers and if you look back at
Biden's history in office and his
campaign he's been spending money on
influencers this whole time I remember
distinct Jens saki had a whole round T
of influencers come into the White House
to tell them all to promote the Ukraine
war um you know I I forget who there was
reporting on that from The Washington
Post I think it was actually Taylor
lorens covered that we also had remember
the the the guy in the white suit with
no shirt yeah which I don't understand a
suit with no shirt like that dry
cleaning bill has got to really be
insane but um he was out there with his
fingernails and his cell phone you know
boosting the White House you've had over
remember that guy he was the worst guy
he was he was doing like a day in the
life of the you know intern at the White
House awful and then over the summer you
had um was it not this past summer but
the previous summer you had Biden
brought in a whole bunch of social media
influencers to tell them why it's
important to have child sex changes and
all kinds of stuff like that you had
Dylan malaney in the White House do the
dude was took his shirt off and was like
on the White House lawn is that the one
no that was that was June Pride this
year and it was dude no it was it was a
dude Oh I thought you were talking about
there was was there was males and
females there were males and females the
females had no breasts and the men had
lar uh here's a question for you if a
pro trump super pack came to us and said
we want to give you $100,000 to promote
us and do a read should we accept that I
don't think we should because number one
we're all actually different entities
and so it would be confusing to to see
our individuals opinions away from the
brand and they also think that
ultimately at least for me nothing to do
with like should the show except a
sponsorship that's a political
sponsorship supporting a candidate what
if they were to pay us a lot of money
should I do like hey this episode's
brought to you by Trump is the best.com
you lose credibility yeah I think it
makes you look biased that's what I'm
saying like I think even there's full
disclosure I mean it's Tim show
ultimately so if that's what you wanted
to do that's fair but if we were
operating like the editorial board of a
news room then I wouldn't want to do it
I also don't like when editorial I know
that's what I'm saying I I also don't
like when editorial boards uh endorse
candidates I think that there is a level
of uh is scnr going to endorse I don't
know I me that's up to CHR cand think so
I don't think post Millennials it's up
to Chris Cassandra I don't know why we
would it's up to Chris and Cassandra
because they're the editors it's weird
that news rooms endorse candidates I
don't super weird I don't so my question
then is for for you Libby yeah
personally or organizationally would you
accept uh 50,000 to $100,000 in in
support of from from a pack to support a
candidate to support a candidate well
like
but I would accept ad dollars we want a
post that makes insert candidate looks
good uh oh like sponsored content well
however however a pack would pay for an
influencer to promote like you make a
post saying hey this is me a this
person's awesome advertorial on the post
millennial or human events or something
I don't think so I would take ad dollars
if you wanted to buy ads like for your
political campaign I would probably take
ad dollars for that I think that would
be fine I don't know that I would be in
favor of doing an
advertorial I I'm I'm not crazy about uh
Shady it's even more shady when it's the
like the Tik Tok post it's it's triing
people look like it's or product and
it's not organic and they're paid I
think that's here's the bigger risk I'll
tell you the F the one reason why I
would not accept it because the rules
around political advertising are intense
and that's a nightmare to navigate well
and then you'd have to take anybody's
political advertising not necessarily
isn't that what the isn't that what the
TV stations had to do uh I I it it
depends on the structure of how you're
ads are done if you don't have the
inventory you can't sell the inventory
we're so far past TV if I own but a
single roll of toilet paper and a
Democrat wants to buy it and a
republican wants to buy it only one of
them is getting it but the bigger issue
is not if I had a single roll of toilet
paper I wouldn't sell it the issue is
not the the issue of is it appropriate I
think you end up running into the
problem of Democrats have no issue
whatsoever taking money from powerful
political organizations to make fake
content Y and then people on the right
are like well you know I think that's
wrong we shouldn't do it and so I'm just
like
yeah there's an issue of we have we have
we have limits on this show of what
we're willing to accept in terms of
sponsorship we've had people try to buy
their way onto the show we never allow
people to come on the show and exchange
for money that is not allowed and uh but
I recognize the challenge of so long as
people on the right who are opposing The
Establishment reject this standing on
their moral High Ground the Democrats
will keep having the advantage because
they have no scles it's one of the
things that actually works against us as
as conservatives is you know we we
wonder how do they always get these
people out in into the into these big
frenzy out into these Big Bobs or
whatever it's because Democrats are a
group mentality it's easier to H them
into one certain thing whereas
conservatives we're just like I just
want to be left alone just want to live
my life I want to raise my family you
know start a business and and and this
aspect it's kind of used against us yeah
I I think that's similar I think the uh
acceptance for individual difference
it's much higher among conservative
communities than it is in on the left
which is sort of the inverse of what
they mark it right they say tolerant
we're accepting but we're actually not
uh we expect you to fall on line and we
expect you to be okay with the things
that we're okay with and I think that's
sort of the big lie that they have sold
a lot of generations and a lot of really
misguided people who feel um anxiety
within themselves they don't feel
comfortable with who they are and so
they think I'll just run to whoever's
accepting but I have to earn that
acceptance by complying completely and
totally with their world view and that's
very different especially from you know
every every variation of a conservative
Community I've personally experience
that's interesting yeah it's weird I
mean I think it is the big uh Democrats
have and well I don't say Democrats left
leaning causes whether it's Democrat or
just different organizations have always
done a really good job of getting out of
have of messages and spinning them and I
think this is something that Republicans
struggle with in this case like talking
out endorsement or whatever else like I
think ultimately I have to live with
myself and I would rather try to find
another way to tackle the advantage than
to just do what they're doing because I
again like I have to live with myself at
the end of the day well and back to your
point of the left like they will accept
you until you step out of line and it
the perfect example of that is the
people who were transitioning they sung
their praises and were like oh and then
when someone wanted to detransition
because they're like wait a second I
made a mistake they like the left
attacked these people I mean Weir if
they were tolerant wouldn't they just be
like yeah everyone has a different
experience gender Journey or whatever
one of the most frustrating things for
me uh is daily wire uh posted a video on
X it's Ben Shapiro debating Destiny and
Ben defines woke and Ben is wrong in the
majority of his definition what did he
say he defines woke as this this idea
ideology rooted in post-modernism he
gives a long definition but he basically
says it's about power structures it's
about you know those who in power tend
to be bad and I'm paraphrasing rather
poorly but he basically gives this IDE
ideological woke is you know
postmodernism with a racial component
and then gender ideology it's totally
wrong wokeness means adherence to the
social Orthodoxy of dominant
institutions that's it that explains why
so the issue is for someone like Ben I
can understand why he would say it this
way he's a Politico political junkie so
he's looking at all the highest level
things and wokeness is identifiable in
its root form the average person who
says woke does not mean any of that
because they don't understand what that
is and so they'll refer to a woke person
because they're flying the Ukraine flag
or something in their profile picture
why is it that there's an overlap
between those support critical race
theory gender ideology and supporting
war in Ukraine perhaps the argument can
be made that because Russia is the power
and Ukraine is weaker therefore Russia
is bad well that doesn't really make
sense because the US is funding Ukraine
to the tune of hundreds of billions of
dollars in fact supporting Ukraine is
supporting Western imperialism and
hegemony so why would they support going
to war against Russia for Russia's
border dispute we in the west are the
dominant power because all that really
matters is woke is a reference to when
someone adheres to the social Orthodoxy
of the dominant institutions and it's a
morphous sometimes it's woke sometime
like sometimes it's see I woke in the
esoteric sense sometimes it's
postmodernist critical race theory
gender ideology sometimes it's
absolutely not and Everyone Falls in
line the the best way to understand this
is how the left uses a Mot and Bailey
tactic if the left was truly if woke
truly was postmodernism there would be
no mtin Bailey they'd quite literally
say here's our argument have a nice day
but they don't they change their
argument to a civil libertarian argument
when threatened showing there is no
actual ideology here it is simply just
we are a group that is in line with each
other we look for others who are wearing
the same color clothing and so long as
we do that and we are up to date on the
on the latest fashion we are aligned
that's what woke is I describe it as a a
bunch of birds flying in the sky
flooding in a random flooding flying in
random directions they occupy a very
specific space you can see them oh
they're over the lake yes they have this
weird leftist postmodernist thing to
them but they're really flying around
and they could move at a moment's notice
so I tweeted a picture of something
called an ant Mill you guys ever heard
of this no no ants uh when they walk
they leave fairmon trails to signal to
other ants where they went what they're
doing they come back with food and they
can follow that line so you notice this
in your kitchen the line of ants an ant
Mill is when the ants get turned around
and form a circle what happens is they
follow pheromones in a Circle forever
until they run out of until they starve
to death what it's called a March of
death as well March of death a death
Circle in the middle so they'll just
walk in a circle until they wow because
they can't see the big picture yeah
they're a tiny ant and to them they're
just following the path and the path is
one big circle and they're all following
each other and more and more keep
funneling in until they eventually just
starve to death or dehydration and die
that's wokeness you join the circle
they're all following each other you say
what is the ideology they hold
whatever the ideology of the person in
front of them holds it could be anything
well it's a shifting sand that's why
wixon is offensive today but not
offensive tomorrow it's why women with a
why is offensive today not tomorrow
because postmodernism is just a current
component of the cult ant Mill ideology
and it can become imperialist Western
hemony at a moment's notice yeah so one
day they're saying power structures are
bad the next day they're like we support
NATO expansionists on the Russian border
it's Whiplash it's Whiplash yeah the
between that and the conspiracy theories
and it's because I I I think very
strongly that the the leftist ideology
is a shifting sand you wherever you put
your foot down now is not the same as
it's going to be soon and they always
act like there has been no change but
it's actually not aligned on any moral
foundation and I think that's a big
difference like conservatism as an idea
is on a moral Foundation yep there you
go that's what it looks like army ants
trapped in a death Circle all just SP
around confused sometimes they can break
out of it usually they don't someone
actually posted the video you can see it
right here let's see if we can uh pull
this one up they just walk in a circle
this is this is how I view wokeness I've
I've often described it as this
Whirlpool that spins faster and faster
some people get ejected from it because
it's been so fast they wake up and they
realize how bad things are but for
people who are saying things like woke
is postmodernist ideology and that's
what we mean by woke and yeah you might
but the average person sees this going
on and so if if one day someone is
claiming like Hassan perer is a really
great example of this because he made a
video where I had defended something he
had said about Mr Beast Mr Beast was
providing cataract surgeries and Hassan
said it's it's ridiculous that we're
cheering this on when we could be doing
this instead we're wasting all this you
know we waste money we don't have
Healthcare I said Hassan is correct it
is silly that Mr Beast is effectively a
game show curing people's cataract
blindness and I was like Meanwhile we're
sending $100 billion do to Ukraine yeah
Hassan responded by insulting me and
mocking me for criticizing the money
being sent to Ukraine this is the
perfect example a a man who's like why
aren't we giving people cataract surgery
also send $100 billion to Ukraine there
is no moral pathway or ideology he's
just saying whatever is socially
acceptable within the dominant
institutions running in a circle until
they eventually and here's here's here's
eventually here's the harsh part they
abort their kids yep yep they more like
are to sterilize their kids they
advocate for things that result in self
harm and death and so I view wokeness
quite literally as a death spiral where
over a long enough period of time these
people and their ideas will cease to
exist it's crazy I mean it collapses in
in on itself really uh some of it to me
with this how I mean how does this occur
this this Death March some of it I think
is turns no no what I mean is like among
among woke people is um I think some of
it is the language that you there like
when you respond to Hassan yes so don't
send money to Ukraine he knows he's
supposed to be in in support of Ukraine
and so that's something he can't argue
with right so he has to be like well
you're wrong it's these sort of terms
that they're like like when you heard uh
you know the Israel Palestine conflict
this whichever side gets described as
colonizer that's where a lot of young
progressives will line up behind because
they know the colonizer is always wrong
no matter what and it becomes this very
uh routine way of handling things and
again it eliminates all critical
thinking yeah but
except when it's the West doing the
colonizing they're against that it's
because they're told what to think
instead of being taught how to think for
themselves this is what's really funny
about it the US supports Israel Israel
is engaged in a conflict with Hamas in
Gaza and the left is on the side of
Palestine and Gaza the west then also
funds Ukraine and NATO expansionist
policies onto the Russian
border so these
people not all of them but many of them
like
goes off on Israel mhm but defends
Ukraine it's weird which which US
Imperial hegemonistic policy are you
opposed to today Hassan it goes back and
forth I guess whatever the Mocking Bird
media told them to to
say no I think it's whatever his
commenters told him to say and so all
the people start spamming him and it's
probably it's just Bots it's it's like
sock puppets what you'll get is one guy
running 50 accounts he'll respond to
someone and say this thing good this
thing bad this thing good and then these
people who are susceptible to it read
their comments oh you know what I got to
tell you I talked about The Vaping thing
the other day how really frustrates me
what what frustrates you about vaping we
we we're not we can't have vaping in
here for legal reasons okay uh legally
many most laws look at vaping and
smoking is the exact same so there's no
distinction and so we have signs saying
no vaping people come in here and
they'll do it anyway oh that's rude oh
it's crazy the craziest thing is when
I'm driving in a car with someone and
they just blast Vape in the car and I
was like I'm I'm I'm going to kick you
out I'm so anyway I was pointing it out
and now I lost my train of thought what
were we just talking about before before
you asked me you were talking about how
you were talking about vaping the other
day no before that we're talking about
um gosh what were we all missed it I'm
sorry cuz I mentioned that you asked me
about it then I describe it we need a
reporter to read back the notes I forgot
lost my train of thought it's over
conversation done I'm sorry I'm so sorry
but I'm sure it was a point I was
interested in it no I think I mean I
think all this Con I was just trying to
understand the point fully and I screwed
everything up okay Tim was talking about
people responding to Hanan saying this
thing good this thing bad right and then
nope I don't know if we're going to get
there I can't remember well you were
talking about vaping the other day we
were talking about vaping the other day
did you as a middle school teacher have
to deal with kids vaping oh yeah I mean
absolutely it's unbelievable honestly
anyone who's who's in to teaching for
the correct reasons um it is a very
difficult job I mean it it really is
there's
it it's really sad and it's one of the
reasons I left got out I've been in real
estate for seven or eight years now and
which is amazing and what made you want
to do it in the first place so uh so I
mean I wanted to I wanted to coach
football and and be involved and wanted
to have the same schedule as my kids and
wanted to kind of give back to my
community I mean I was really the the
thinking behind it at the time and you
get in there and then you realize it's
just uh bunch of paperwork it's just a
bunch of I saw the woke stuff the
liberal ideology coming down and I'm not
a very quiet person I already knew this
was not going to to end very well uh for
me and so I wanted to get out of that
and then uh obviously the pay sucks and
so it's nobody goes into it for the pay
uh but really I think the biggest issue
once again is that they have they've
weaponized um the the young Educators
coming out of college and through
indoctrination like that's truly it's a
scary thing they really believe it's
their job to over appearance go ahead
let's go the frustrating thing is when
people come on this show and they just
read the comments the whole time and
then they start saying and thinking
insane things and we have to warn people
do not read the comments like the chat's
fine I'm what about chat or or uh uh
super chats I'm saying we put up Clips
don't read the comments don't waste your
time okay you you you are not ready for
this some people are ready for this you
are not ready for this and then what
happens is I watch people's brains
shatter not everyone is capable of
handling the internet and so I think you
know so you know I'm probably going to
start on Twitter just uh only verified
accounts can respond to me at this point
it's a waste of time because of the sock
puppets and uh I think a lot of the
disantis supporters are sock puppet
accounts because they all have like a
cartoon character with a fake
name no re no history until the disantis
thing and then they all say the same
things right on Q and I'm like this is
one guy who's got who's just switching
accounts or something stupid it's not
legitimate yeah but switch to you know
on Twitter I'll switch to just verified
only and then I know that these people
have actually paid for an account at the
very least harder to Sock up at that but
there are a lot of people who don't
realize they'll come on this show and
they'll be like here's what I think then
I'll hear from one of their RS or you
know one of their employees or them
later on and they'll be like everybody
was really mad about insert issue and
I'll be like were they were they or was
it like a handful of people who spammed
the comment and out of the 10,000
comments that we received you read 30 of
them and then you think that's public
sentiment yeah so that's what happens to
people like Hassan he'll he'll be
talking online
people will start spamming his chat and
he'll be like I agree with whatever
they're saying because it makes me money
interesting yeah I'm with you though I
only read the verified comments because
I I mean I get so many people from the
left specifically who just hate me
because of mainly January 6 and and you
know where I stand on a lot of these
issues but I don't even waste my time
reading through those because it's it
would take forever to do that and most
of them are probably fake so I don't pay
it's probably not real uh if you were to
go to look um National Harbor in over in
DC big feris wheel a bunch of
restaurants I go there it's DC Urban
liberal and people are like oh man I'm a
big fan of the show if you were to
believe what these people are spamming
on Twitter I couldn't go to these places
everybody hates me yeah I go to
Pittsburgh I it was it was crazy I I've
never been recognized more in my life
but Pittsburgh is anti foot toown what
do you mean they want you to think that
so we had a a show several years ago in
was it Pitman New Jersey two weeks
before the show antifa threatened to
burn the theater down I remember this I
was there yeah and the and the guy who
runs theater was like I can't I can't
I'm terrified I cancel your contract
despite saying he could handle an couter
and the protest are meaningless and then
I think like 12 people shut up to
protest yeah that's how it goes yep yeah
I mean the the fear is how they keep
certain people compliant right I mean
I've known other uh organizations that
have had cancels contract over and over
again because there is a possibility
maybe that someone bad show up but you
know you are from the community that you
represented and when you went through
January 6 people react to you right oh
my my community loves me for it honestly
no no the support is amazing and I tell
everyone the fear of being canceled in a
lot of ways is worse than being canceled
so like I can't get a banking account at
most major Banks get at Major Banks I
can y can't get a credit card at a major
Bank can get a loan any of those things
I'm I'm considered a domestic terrorist
by this Administration can't travel
freely in this country but you know what
once again we our routs do not come from
the government our RS come from God we
have natural god-given routs and so we
can't give that up out of fear of what
what's going to happen to us and that's
what's taking place in our country did
you see that juval Harari clip did you
guys see that it was a clip of juval
Harari doing a TED Talk talking about
how uh human rights are just a fiction
we came up with and they don't really
exist and I thought I don't yeah but
like right but I mean you could say lots
of things are made up right but I don't
agree that natural rights are a fiction
I believe that they were God I mean in
the sense that uh humans at the at at
the bar minimum have come to realize
some things are good and some things are
bad and we've agreed upon those things
and we consider it evil to do those
things but if we don't maintain that
perspective if we don't maintain that
perspective then we'll be in a
completely aoral society which is kind
of where we're heading are we we have we
have agents smuggling humans right we
also have the Biden Administration the
incumbent president his main policy
platform right now is killing babies
yeah do people use that's so wacky uh
natural rights and human rights
interchangeably cuz I feel like the same
I feel like they're not the same I was
listening to it and I was thinking they
were the same thing oh see I think of
Human Rights like I think of you know
the Constitution the rights that we
given by God separately and I think of
like uh everyone's guaranteed uh water
as a human right everyone's guaranteed
Medical Care as like when people use
that sort of expansive terminology for
human rights which we hear all the time
that's sort of what I think that is
applying to but maybe I'm misinterpreted
if he says human rights are something
are a fiction we've made up yeah like
healthcare being a human right exactly
that's madeup thing so when I when I
when I look at god-given rights I think
of like the things that exist in reality
like you can speak yes and you can
defend yourself things like that yeah
well I was talking about it on Twitter
and someone was like you know
imagination must be made up because we
can't can we can't Envision we can't see
that either we imagined imagination we
imagined imagination that must be but
but it really goes back to the once
again our youth have been taught and I
would argue indoctrinated into believing
that our RS come from from the
government they look to the government
when that they think think it's the
government's role to protect them to
feed them to clothe them to house them
to keep them safe that's not the
government's role that's not that's
that's our role as you know as as
individuals and leaders of our families
as men to do those things and and right
now it's uh people are being trained to
look to the government for all of their
answers and that's a scary place to be
that's definitely what they're trying to
do trying to make you want to go to the
government because everything is such
chaos you go towards the government and
they become the organiz
they become the Saving Grace it's an old
ma thing it's what Ma would do all the
time he did it constantly if you look
through his re in China he would do
things where he essentially would create
chaos so chaos so Discord and then be
this already have a plan in place for
how he's going to suddenly come back and
save everybody and be this Shining Light
and just be this amazing figure it's
amazing well what's the saying I'm from
the government I'm here to help is like
the worst thing you could ever hear you
know and and then you think about it so
many times as Americans specifically we
give up freedoms all in the name of
safety so look at the Patriot Act Right
Now is being weaponized against all of
us but at the time it was the Americans
were cheering it on people were saying
yeah we need the patrio because I don't
patri I did as well but so many people
were like we need that because I don't
feel safe I the government need to keep
me safe fear out of fear Biden ran on
safety in 2020 exactly you mentioned uh
men leading their families why do you
think there are so many men who don't
want to lead their families well this
all started uh back under the attack on
on on the nuclear family which is under
attack in this country and if you
remember I don't know probably 10 years
ago was The Toxic masculinity and that's
what they first started stripping down
they started stripping that down and
made it toxic to be masculine and made
it toxic to want to be a provider and a
protector of of your family and so then
when they stripped that down now they
can go into well men can be women
because if there's no difference why
can't men be women and women be men so
it all we all talk about this
transgender issue right now in my
opinion it all started originally with
the attack on quote unquote toxic
masculinity but that's what it comes
down to do you think that men have
masculinity modeled them modeled to them
in a way that they can then recreate
later because I almost wonder if that's
some of the issue well I mean it is part
of the issue once again the nuclear
family's been under attack for decades
in this family so there's a lot of uh
young men especially growing up without
any sort of uh male role model in their
in their life whether that's a father a
grandfather an uncle or a coach of some
sort they just they don't have that and
there's a lot of studies that's been
showing too when uh you put a male um
educator in like an elementary school
how much it really impacts the the young
boys in that environment because you
don't see that that very often
especially the ones who don't have a
male role model at home and so I I think
that once again we got to get back to
there's nothing toxic about wanting to
look we have a generation and a society
full of weak men right now that's what a
lot of this culture stuff in our in our
world is is a result of weak men because
our grandparents generation who were
strong men they would never stand by and
allow this attack on our women do you
think my grandparents generation would
stand by and allow men to go change with
their with with their daughters in
school and and participate against them
in sports there's no way that they would
allow this to happen we have a society
full of weak men I completely agree and
weak men make hard times yep but we will
uh we will talk more about this in the
members only uncensored show so smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
go to
timcast.net this for the past couple of
days all right Christopher Lambert says
burp unfortunately councilman Robert
suen box says first no burp was first so
you you didn't you didn't get that one
hard defeat there that's very upsetting
all right in the next Super Chat we have
token black guy who says hey Tim will
the Republicans ever grow a pair they
won't nope but the Republicans will be
replaced by men who do have some so
there you go I'm in Disguise says my
conspiracy theory they're getting people
used to living in pods and eating
disgusting things bugs so that when we
start flying in space we're already used
to that
stuff yeah I like the the wild
conspiracy theory that all of life is
actually a training pod we are on a
colony ship headed to Alpha centari once
your life ends you wake up as a young
child with the full knowledge of a human
life and that's how they train people
for the new uh human colonies that would
be cool that would that's a cool movie
they should make a movie that you know
why cuz then you get another chance but
guess what to be alive like I would just
want to live forever hold
on so you have this large Colony ship
flying from Earth to colonize a new
planet in alpha santario or wherever
humans are created in in in pods and
then put into a simulation program to
develop into natural humans
understanding the full culture and
Technology of earth when they left
because if they were raised on this
sterile spaceship they would be weird
dejected people they need social
experience however you need to sort some
of these people will be bad evil
murderous people some of them will be
good so as these people are being
trained and when they come to the end of
their lives and they die the system will
then judge them you in this training
program did horrible awful things
eject launches them out into space Oh
you terrible are a good person who lived
a good moral life and we want you to be
a part of the greater Society in the New
Colony your pot opens up and you wake up
and you're like 7 years old and you're
like this is the weirdest thing ever
that would be weird and it's like but
now you have lived a full adult life and
you are a functioning well attuned
person are there really people who
believe this like this is like a real
thing or is this you making this up on
the C this is pretty good it's like the
craziest uh Rose ceremony in The
Bachelor of all time you get to stay who
wants to make the movie you get a car I
mean you did a great job making that up
on the fly man it sounded like it was
something you well I've talked about
something similar before but you know
we'll we'll make a movie about it all
right let's grab some more Wrath of Paul
says Shan Strickland had had originally
won the fight but then ended up losing
to drias dupi after additional punches
were discovered at 3:00 inm 3:00 a.m.
the next morning that's right yeah they
they they actually said we're going to
stop the judge count and we'll come back
tomorrow and then in the middle of the
night people were rushing in boxes of
takedowns and Strikes that the judges
then used and uh I hear juliani has
video of that that's
right Ian Kenny says Tim if you think
the Samsung AI is wild you should listen
to the Malay speech in English rendered
using hey Jen in his own voice I've seen
it and it makes his lips move in English
you know the future is is
broken I don't know man you know that
the idea I had about the spaceship going
to the col going to uh colonizer planet
was because I was thinking if it takes a
100 years to to travel or 200 years
human beings growing up on on a
spaceship would be maladjusted broken
people who would not be able to colonize
how do you program a human to understand
life on earth work and all of these
things so that when they arrive on that
planet they're ready for this they you
know you could freeze them cryogenic
storage or whatever cryogenic storage
and then they wake up that's how sci-fi
typically does it I'm like I like my
idea better yeah I like your idea
everyone's in a simulation I think
that's really fun yeah you're basically
being you know what that would be is a
that would be a really good video game
interesting and then what would the
conflict be that the AI the algorithm
breaks and some bad people emerge and
the colonies splits into two factions I
think the I think the conflict would be
avoiding fascism in the simulation just
like it is right now it's space Lord of
the Flies right there you go yeah right
on all
right aor says trumpa Swami 20124 the
polling's looking good for V's VP but
we'll see he doesn't have the experience
I don't know neither did Trump trump had
no experience exective no executive
experience and also the VP job um I know
I say this all the time but nobody does
anything in that job ever since Adams
nobody has done anything in that job so
if Viet comes in and has no experience
and doesn't know what the job of VP is
he's going to do a way better job than
all the VPS for like he would and
actually make it so they have to do
something I think it's about time the VP
actually became a real job well Harris
Harris had experience and she's in
charge of the border right now we said
but she's she's a tiebreaker in the
Senate that's her whole job yeah yeah
she's she's effectively a senator the
only other argument that I've heard is
that this VP might be a big deal
depending on you know Trump's legal
cases and everything else there's
there's a possibility that this VP has
to take over at some point I don't know
how ACC true with Biden and his total
deranged brain that facing the same
legal pressure that Trump is uh but I
agree it' be cool to have someone who
actually makes it interesting and so
that the next time there's a VP that
person is like well now I can't just do
do nothing I don't think the people
other than KLA Harris who become VP want
to do nothing I think it's just that
they're sort of traditionally nothing
for them to do but if someone breaks
that tradition if someone breaks that
tradition someone perhaps with no
experience and no executive office in
Trump right now people I think are
looking and saying the vp's got to be
the person who takes over after
president Trump and I don't think that
necessarily has to be the case and I'll
just be honest with you I don't care who
he picks his VP I'm voting for president
Trump in in 2024 I don't care he picks
his VP well the question too is is there
anybody could pick for VP that would get
people who aren't going to vote for him
to vote for him question I feel like
there's not that many people who have
just an open mind in this country when
it comes to our political leaders at
this point is there a person you know
who's not voting for Trump who could be
swayed or who's not voting for Biden who
could be swayed based on the VP no based
yeah based on the VP at this point I
don't think that would really have any
impact it's kind of like a you know band
that doesn't need a an opening act
anymore well the more likely uh scenario
or outcome come there would be to try to
find someone who could potentially
deliver one of these swing States maybe
someone from one of the Swing States who
has a I don't know I'm just throwing
stuff out there to your point but that
would probably be the more likely
situation there is finding someone who
could deliver a swing stick and kind of
take that off the the board there to
where they could focus on other areas
and I think in some ways people are
expecting the VP to set the tone of
where the Maga movement will go after
like maybe even if it isn't who runs in
2028 it's just sort of an indication of
who Trump sees as a potential
figurehead or a leader of the movement
forward and so some ways I think you're
right it's not that it'll sway voters
but I think it does internally have some
um psychological impact on people who
already support trump it should be
someone who can be on the campaign Trail
independently well someone who can be
trusted someone who's going to be loyal
and and not stab president Trump or the
Maga supporters in the back when they
get a chance and opportunity to do so
that's the key thing that's sort of what
we saw with Dan santis like Dan santis
kept essentially being not very very
nice to the Trump voters y yeah saying
like yeah I don't need your vote
whatever let's read some more Paul Barn
says I have a structured settlement and
I need cash now does anyone know the
number
877 uh cars for
kids z cash now yeah JG Wentworth 877
877 cashell everybody knows that it's
the most effective commercial I think
cars for kids is more effective you have
a structured settlement and you need
cash
now Wentworth it's just the best
commercial they they they they nailed it
everyone's on the bus singing there's a
guy in the Viking costume or whatever
it's a commercial on that that in the
and the weird chinchilla thing screaming
about eating sub sandwiches that's my f
my new some commercials you'll never
that was amazing I think all campaigns
to take a leave out of Quiznos book well
I mean that's that's you know that's
what we're doing with cast Brew we had
uh uh Alex Stein try to free base coffee
you know we just told Alex Stein to
figure it out and he did and it was fun
he did free base the coffee no Do Not
Free based coffee you cannot but he you
know he had like the spoon and he's
lighting he's like this isn't working
it's the world we live in you have to
put a disclaimer out there to not free
based coffee did he just put the coffee
in and nothing else he what he just put
he end he ended up drinking the coffee
spoil it for you I do I should watch the
commercial I haven't seen it Mark Junior
says Tim what do you think of a trump
RFK ticket keep Trump votes and takeway
votes from Biden how would you feel
about it I was I was more in favor of it
a while ago not so much now because RFK
has gone weird and every 's kind of like
what the heck happened to this guy and
it might have maybe it's Epstein related
stuff cuz like wasn't he on the plane or
something like that and I oh see I
always thought it was just that
eventually he wants to end up back in
the good graces of the DNC that's why he
left being independent anyways he wants
to what he wants ultimately he wants the
DNC support in he's he's pretty far left
on a lot of issues such as you know the
climate change stuff and anti-gun stuff
I mean he's that's where he really uh
aligns is with the left
MH
all right barely a millennial says if
Texas were to secede is there any path
for other red States like Indiana to
join them or will it have to move to
Texas I'm half joking I think the border
states would would align on some kind of
uh Regional defense plan for the
southern border so California would not
but Arizona New Mexico uh Texas maybe
even probably might go with them yeah
yeah because it's spilling up mhm
Florida probably would
um the other Gulf Southern States may
just because of location but uh I'm not
saying see I'm saying packed like
Regional defense paact where they defy
the federal government and say we don't
care what you're doing but we're doing
this thing the the question now is Will
Joe Biden order the federal government
to use Force to stop Texas National
Guard if they don't it's going to be
real interesting what other states start
doing well I mean the left leaning
States the liberal states have defied uh
federal law before in terms of like the
sanctuary cities years ago before we got
to this point so but all they do with
Sanctuary cities is not cooperate with
federal law enforcement so you know I
think it was DC Dro who said the ruling
from the Supreme Court could be good
they're saying Federal Supremacy and
immigration yeah that's like California
Sanctuary State all that means is if Ice
shows up they just put their hands up
and say we're not helping helping you
out yeah so ice is compl this totally
different because they're basically
saying we're going to prevent you from
removing these barriers of the Texas
border yeah abolutely different so the
feds would have to go in and use Force
to stop Texas from obstructing them and
if they don't it's almost as bad as if
if they do if they do go in Texas has a
choice to make fight the feds or don't I
hope think they should already be
arresting them I hope the people in
Texas and the leadership in Texas
realizes there are a lot of Patriots out
here in smaller States who don't have
the ability like West Virginia doesn't
have the the resources that Texas does
you know on that level to do this that
we are cheering them on right now and
watching them and they are really
setting the tone uh from that standpoint
if the federal government does not take
action after this ruling it shows the
federal government is impotent and
unable to enforce its own claims of
jurisdiction yeah what kind of action
could they take the feds yeah I mean at
this point they have their border guards
down there Texas is reinstalling the
razor wire no no their border guards are
pushed out of the jurisdiction right
they're not in the Eagle Pass area
they're asserting it and Texas says good
luck the feds would have to forcibly
enter defying Texas's national guard and
the and the
Troopers Texas would then have to make a
choice mhm use Force to to repel Federal
forces coming into the Border I would
love to see some constitutional stuff on
this from a sheriff standpoint as well
could some of these Texas sheriffs have
authority to go in and arrest some of
these people as well do they actually
have real authority to do that I mean
I've heard that they do I don't know but
that's something I would love to see
someone who's smarter than me out there
watching who could look that up and this
isearch this is wild because uh I I I
read the story a long time ago I was
reading about gun rights and stuff like
20 years ago and there were two guys in
Texas or something and uh I felt the
story on the show before but I'll go
through it quick uh guy rearend the
other guy the guy who gets rear ended is
pissed he's armed guy who rear ended him
it was an accident was armed the guy
gets out of the car starts screaming and
yelling about being rear ended the guy
who did the rear ending gets out of the
car says calm down it was an accident he
notices the guy's got a gun the so the
guy gets out of his car and sees this
guy screaming at him and he's open carry
so he puts his hand on his hip and puts
his hand up the guy who's screaming sees
a guy reaching for his gun so he draws
his gun puts it low the guy in the
backat car sees him draw the gun so he
pulls his out and brings it to high
ready the other guy sees him drawing gun
aiming at him shoots him and so that's
how the situation was described the
rapid escalation of you know some guy
gets out screaming at when you see he's
got a gun he puts his hand on his hip
and holds his hand up but the other guy
sees him reaching for a weapon yeah and
it just it dramatically escalates to
that point the fear is I mean it may be
that a a Texas National Guardsman let's
say I don't know 19 years old yeah does
not none of these people want to fight
the feds but what happens when it's 3 in
the morning some CBP guys maybe maybe
plane clothes even they're walking down
there's no National Guard that they see
and they're like we're going to survey
and see what's going on Abbott said he's
putting up razor wire we're going to go
look to see how much is put up and then
report back to our guys as to what's
going on young National Guard guy sees
Silhouettes moving towards him and says
don't move these guys
say like who's like we're not even doing
anything or but like who are you don't
tell me what to do and then it could be
as simple as a young Guardsman or
Trooper does not even know feds are
approaching raises a weapon and says
back up now they say no they draw the
they see a guy with a rifle they they
draw their weapon they say back you know
on the ground they're both y on the
ground at each other drop the weapon
drop the weapon and then Bang Yeah and
then it's possible in a situation like
that they I mean if a situation like
that happens it's going to be a shootout
maybe things calm down after the fact
but it might not even be that Texas
marches forward saying we hereby are
going to fight feds it could simp it
could literally just
be a rapid escalation yeah it could be a
a a one like you ever SE the video of
the ATF agent getting arrested he goes
to the house to to take a shotgun and
then the cops arrest him it could
literally just be that an uh an ATF or
or I mean sorry a CBP guy is walking up
to the border and he goes to talk to
them and they're like drop the weapon
drop the weapon back back the F up now
and he's like I a federal agent you are
you are not I'm going to do this to me
and then he dies right well people are
also forgetting that and when it comes
to Texas I mean their economy is is
larger than a lot of countries I mean
they have they could suceed if they
wanted to and actually sustain
themselves unlike a lot of other states
I mean they they have they control their
grid yeah I mean they they got full
control of a lot of that and so I mean
they could do that and I wonder how much
that's going to play into effect of the
federal government wanting to push this
issue against Texas knowing that they
have the resources and the you know
infrastructure and everything to to
withdraw if they wanted to and it's
actively on the minds of the citizens
yeah it is absolutely this is a ballot
question next year I mean this is it
would be a terrible game of chicken it
really would saddle effing says
the leaked a this leaked audio is
straight out of a Grom or Clancy novel
is this real life it's nuts I'm not sure
I have enough popcorn for this is show
my friends if you haven't and you have
the ability to do so listen to the full
10 minutes I mean at three around 3
minutes and 45 seconds he says what if
they steal the election again
again this is a guy who's like very
powerful people want you to drop out of
the race we're going to we're going to
find a way to pay you money listen what
if they steal the election again mhm so
at the very least some people are saying
oh this this PR election was stolen no
no no no no it proves that very powerful
individuals who are pulling the strings
strings behind the scenes believe it was
correct yeah so whatever you're hearing
in media at Fox News this is an
establishment Guy saying we don't want
you to run so this is someone who
doesn't like Trump Rhino establishment
Republican they think the election was
stolen despite you know Fox News and
other corporate you know
conservatives being like no no
no perhaps the news is in on it yeah
Perhaps Perhaps the news is
it Mega Mikey says we talk about aam's
razor regarding the simplest Solutions
is the correct one but this isn't that
there's another phrase that's very
relevant to this leaked audio and
politics the truth is often Stranger
Than Fiction it's not so much that The
Simple Solution tends to be correct it's
that the solution that makes the least
amount of assumptions tends to be
correct and that uh makes a bit more
sense when you think about it conspiracy
cleaning says Carri Lake's daughter had
her brakes fail in her car shortly after
this look it up she's talked about it
before so what this is like at some
point last year her daughter's breaks
failed Carrie Lake tweeted my breaks are
working and I'm not
suicidal yeah that was that was in July
of last year wow didn't she mention this
as well did she mention mention that her
daughter's breaks no mentioned that she
was uh she was a offered a bribe to get
out of the she has mentioned this this
is the first time the audio came out so
she has mentioned the story before
people told her that she was like people
were like ah she's lying yeah or
exaggerating or whatever and then you
hear this and it's like I don't think
she did it justice in terms of telling
just how chilling this conversation
really was she kind of downplayed it if
anything when you actually hear the
audio if she said a prominent Republican
came to me and offered me a lucrative do
nothing job to bow out of politics and
take the cash and I told him to publicly
Expos these people and he responded he
would be killed if he did she didn't say
that no and the funny thing is when I
when I first saw the story popping up I
listen to the audio the first thing I
see is I see the Audio I I listen to it
and I go holy crap this guy says car he'
be car bombed then I I Google search it
to look at all the various sources in
their take none of them are mentioning
that this guy thought he would be
assassinated if if he was found out to
have exposed this the I will say this
the luckiest thing for him right now is
that the audio was released yeah agreed
because now that he's on vid in the
recording saying my car will blow up
it's less likely to happen cuz you never
know with the Epstein stuff I mean come
on they might just be like well you know
yikes all right let's grab some more
Super chats what do we got
here let's see Matthew Schneider says
Trump 2024 beat Nikki Hillary go Ultra
maga kamag maga I used AI a long time
ago and I told called it to render Super
Saiyan Trump and it made an anime
version of trump with Spike yeah I
remember and so we made a t-shirt that
says kamaga instead of Kamehameha for
those that know Dragon Ball Z it's
hilarious esoteric anime fan I don't
know Millennial guys know what Dragon
Ball Z is Nikki Hillary Dragon Ball Z
was like all the rage for for at least
part of my childood most popular show in
the world yeah all right Jake says Tim
the term you are looking for to describe
Democrats as makavelian
totalitarians I mean that work too
that's interesting I'll take it
yeah what have we here we'll grab some
more Brian Rich says H him operation
chaos was Rush Limba telling Republicans
to switch to Democrats in 2008 and vote
for Hillary to draw draw out primary
with Obama go Trump yeah I'm not a fan
of that I think that's that's that's
scumbaggery but I get it it's a big
dirty game of politics not a fan
everyone's going to try and exploit
everybody else to steal power it's
brutal we just need we need a better
culture we need uh uh honor and
integrity too many weak men in this
country Amen to that bill Hugh says what
if Biden federalizes the Texas National
Guard uh out of the control of Texas
they've already discussed doing that if
they declared that it may actually be
the fastest path towards Civil War so
we're concerned about how it could be
that Texas and CBP end up in a
confrontation that National Guard and
CBP are fighting no idea I don't see a
reason for CBP to go and confront an
armed Guardsmen I don't see a reason for
the guard to go up to the CBP guys and
fight them the cbp's already been
expelled however if Biden declares all
of those armed National Guardsmen now
work for him they're going to be like no
that's crazy and that's when things will
get really wild imagine if some of the
Guardsmen say okay not every guardsman's
going to be a
republican that's true it's going to get
real crazy
yeah I don't like it Andrew Goodman says
please get Carrie Lake back on IRL ASAP
we would always love to have car car
Lake back on IRL and uh we will see what
we can do I liked when she was here I I
don't remember U when it was but Brett
dasic who does pop culture crisis said
he walked into a room and she was there
and the way she greeted him was like as
if she was like a Suburban mom welcoming
her into his home like she just has so
much like warmth and everything and he's
like I I work here like this is where I
hang out she's welcoming me to like our
space but it was very nice that's very
sweet it was it was such a great
description all
right vilans Brazil says what if that
was all AI done by Lake and the
Democrats to make the Republicans look
evil and the only one that people can
elect is Lake because they couldn't buy
her off I was thinking about it the fear
that it's deep fake stuff but the the
conversation's too complicated for it to
be Ai and apparently news OTS have
reached out to others and confirmed that
it's it's him speaking so you know you
never know man what if the AI is taken
over and is doing all of this Carrie
Lake was kidnapped months ago and
there's a robot that has taken her place
just to come on uh IRL and prove that
she's not kidnapped she's just on that
ship you want to know scar be alui soon
the scariest scenario in AI I remember
several years ago people on Twitter were
Google searching photos and videos of
armored vehicles military operations
then they were all hashtag in some fake
City whoa I can't believe this is
happening look at this here's another
video what's going on and so everyone's
in on the joke find a random clip of
military action and make it seem like
there's a mass mobilization occurring
and some people fell for it m what would
happen if a fake political candidate was
created using deep fake technology wow
people start seeing speeches I mean
let's be honest I have not seen Donald
Trump In the
Flesh in nine years I've been I went to
a lot of his rallies so I saw him speak
many times uh no that's not nine years
is not correct when was the last time I
saw him uh I saw him in the flesh in
December if that helps yeah I saw him
recently as well so I saw him at the
White House social media Summit I don't
remember the last time I saw him
physically in person my point is this to
everybody who's listening right now
they've probably not seen him in the
flesh since the last rally if they even
went to one the average person probably
has never seen him in the flesh for all
you know Trump isn't AI generated guy
and it's all fake and and you know or or
Joe Biden or whatever Joe Biden's more
believable with all the glitches oh yeah
that's what it is but imagine in the
future Trump's hand hand like two years
ago oh there you go a long time ago now
a long time ago that's where we're
headed with with AI though that that's
really scary to think about that that
they could create I mean some of the uh
I was reading an article I don't get on
there but I read an article one of the
top like only fans type of creators is
an AI it's likei girlfriend yeah it's
not a real person it's crazy
I I think that this uh AI generated
politician is another brilliant film
idea Grim wolf says Tim always forgets
about the Bundy Ranch standoff no I
don't we had em and Bundy on this show
to to break it all down for us y but I'm
not sure I understand the difference
between a small faction of guys fighting
with the Bureau of Land Management
versus an entire State sending its armed
National Guard to strip the jurisdiction
from federal agents those are very
different things a very large state with
lot of resources and a lot of money I
yeah I mean what is what is Texas the
second largest or third largest second
right yeah I think so B Alaska no it's
is California really yeah I'm pretty
sure I don't know I could be wrong land
mass yeah yeah it might even not be as I
mean what is it like California Texas
New York I thought California was Alaska
is the largest oh right right right
Alaska California Texas which what is
Alaska Texas California Mont W Texas is
second biggest yaza they a lot of cows
too you know they got a lot of beef to
eat they say Wars are fought on the
solders belly you know so you got those
cows everywhere
man yeah but what is yeah nobody knows
what to do with cows though Texas
ranchers do they're doing ranchers the
ranchers do no I was just I'm like
imagining soldiers being like there's a
cow I'll eat it yeah yeah yeah have you
seen that show was like 18 70 what is it
what 1881 or whatever 1884 1884 1884 no
why can we not remember this because
1884 yeah isn't there a Cas scene where
they're like I guess we have to eat the
horses yeah absolutely and people in
West Virginia during the reevolu those
people in Texas would know what to do I
don't know people in New York people in
people in New York City 1883 it's a I
don't know how to do anything it's a
problem Upstate New York would be okay
I'm a huge John Dutton fan I think he's
a great guy for shutting down Montana to
the outside people that's a bummer
they're canceling that show though I I'm
really mad about it I would to see one
time in person just go off in Wasington
DC what did they what did they call uh d
a hick lib maybe yeah I think Jack B was
calling that all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net supporting the entire
operation everything we do and uh
there's a reason why we don't do as many
ad reads for those of you that listen to
a bunch of other podcast you may know
notice all of them will always insert
crazy ads all the time all over the
place in the audio version we've got ads
periodically on the the live show I
don't do shout out I don't do any any
hard reads on the YouTube live which is
the most and most of our viewership and
it's because you guys as members make it
so we don't really have to there is a
reality we could make some substantially
more money if I started you know what
they want me to do these agents were
like Tim do an ad read 1 minute in do an
ad read 15 minutes in 30 45 and I was
like no way dude that sounds awful
breaking the conversation and be like
all right let's move on to this before
we do let's talk about I don't want to
do it so uh I appreciate everybody who's
a member you make it possible for us to
just kind of do the show the way we do
it so smash that like button like I said
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
Derek do you want to shout anything out
yeah I just want to say thank you guys
and and to the audience these these are
real people genuine down to earth
definitely worth supporting um yeah I'm
running for congress in West Virginia if
you're in West Virginia check us out you
can go to my website Evans forw v.com
that's Evans for wv.com and you can also
follow me on Twitter X whatever it's
called Dereck Evans uh for WV so head on
over there that's awesome it's been fun
having you here yeah appreciate you guys
this been awesome yeah uh I'm Hannah
Clair brimo I'm a writer for cnr.com
it's an awesome team I hope you check
out our work you can see it uh on social
media if you go to if you follow timcast
news on X and Instagram if you want to
follow me personally I'm on Instagram at
han. and I'm on X at hcbm guys thank you
so much for watching Libby thanks for
being here yeah thank you guys thanks
for uh having me on I'm Libby Emmons I'm
the editor with the post millennial and
you can check out all the great work
we're doing over there at the post
millennial.age that I was kind of like
trying to swap the screens and I missed
that the last part there so oh I'm a
member of Tim cast yeah there you go so
if you want to be like Libby you'd be a
member yeah for Real uh I am surge.com I
am not cutting my hair stop telling me
to cut my hair I'm not going to do it uh
we'll see you in the after show we will
see you all over at timcast.net